four three two
foot soldiers assembled i am your host
ethan klein
seven almost a seven on wiki feet not
quite
but close do you think and of course eli
klein the legendary
uh five-star general thank you
good luck we kind of have our own cult
with the foot soldiers don't we would
you guys storm the capitol building for
me
if i told you the election was stolen
james charles the election was stolen
what do you think
no too late this is challenging hello
give me the oh no we were just doing it
before we went live
oh no i love that sound buddy
anyway yes the title of the podcast is
not clickbait it is a legitimate
question was james
charles inside the capitol building was
james trump outside the capitol building
i'm just asking questions has he
accounted for where he
was does he have an alibi interesting
that is so true
right like i'm just saying
there's no evidence as far as i'm aware
that he wasn't there
but there is evidence that he's a super
spreader which we'll get into later
who's this episode brought to you by me
undies thank you dan this episode is
sponsored by me
undies what a week it's our first week
back this is our first after dark since
coming back thank you to everyone who's
becoming a member in the chat i see you
i love you
god bless you mother efforts we're gonna
have to try to make
more of an effort to um post the videos
early
you know i think we should just start
dan going forward we should just post
them
the evening of whenever just boom
like including frenemies you know okay
yeah
we're gonna just start getting them all
up the day before because you know what
we got we gotta do it we gotta do it the
problem is we've just been it's just
everything's so tight
you know well we didn't actually record
a normal episode this week
yeah because of what happened right our
normal episode was alive
yeah well anyway you guys will be happy
to know that i'm not here to discuss
about politics
at all i have erased that from the
document because this is
after dark where we come to have fun
have laughs
goof around spoof around and wonder
so here was james charles the q and on
shaman
oh my god this is the t is he a q and
shaman
um what's causing you to ask the
question
i'm just saying what was his alibi where
was he
at the time have you ever seen the q and
on shaman and james charles in the same
place
no i have not yeah it's kind of kind of
suspicious kind of like
superman you never see him with call our
ken but you know um
can we put on screen the q and charming
i'm sure everyone know who that guy is
the queue this guy's going to jail for
sure by like wait
we said we're not going to talk about
politics but okay i'll just show this
image
the q anon shaman is this guy who's
apparently antifa deep undercover
according to right wing media
this guy that is so true it seems like
the vast majority of people who did
storm the capital were q affiliated
dude i gotta give shout out to people
who make tattoos where they're nipped
have a cut out for the nip you know what
i mean like that's real [ __ ]
we love you you're very special we love
you cubanon shaymin
yeah i heard that one guy who was who uh
i just heard this morning i'm not gonna
get political
this is just this is just kind of fun
and interesting stuff uh nancy pelosi's
office photo this guy who took
the infamous photo in her
chair hello internet is anybody home
yeah this guy he got arrested you know
what's crazy like these
like seriously if you don't think white
privilege exists
it's going into the capital without
covering your face
taking photos schmoozing going back to
the hotel
having cigars and then he doesn't even
realize he's really
gonna get in trouble this guy's got
arrested he's going to jail for 20 years
oops you're very special whoopsie
[Laughter]
we love you you're very you're a great
patriot that being said the fbi
is looking for you and uh you're going
to probably jail for 20 years
you know and the guy stealing the podium
it's like bro like the guy really thinks
he could just
walk into the capitol and walk out with
the podium and people were posting about
themselves right like
live streaming it was all over it's it's
kind of funny like
with social media you kind of want to
post anything you do
so but they don't realize that
it's like they don't understand a world
where the police are actually going to
come arrest them for doing something
like that you know what i mean yeah well
i think in their minds too
like this was it they were taking over
the government like yeah what a
half-baked idea they literally walked in
the capital they're like all right well
all right cool we're done like also the
q and on people are all obsessed with
like the secret cabal of pedophiles in
the government
yeah couldn't you like search around for
the files or
found the evidence like taking selfies
and stuff maybe
apparently um they did steal nancy
pelosi's laptop which is pretty crazy
really yeah
free victory crazy victory victory
victory victory
anyway i promise i want to talk about
this stuff so
we're out out yeah you know i have a
funny story i didn't tell you guys about
uh on monday we shot the frenemies
episode the steamies and i was wearing a
tuxedo
yeah and we had a really funny anecdote
because
we had abe went to get this tux for me
and we had to take my measurements
and i took like my shoulder measurements
and my waist measurements and all that
and the tailor said the ab he goes
he starts giving a b a hard time he's
like these measurements don't make any
sense
he says sir i have never in all my time
as a tailor
encountered a man with these
measurements you're yanking my chain
because we measured ethan like up here
and then at the hips and it was the same
measurement i said i'm a two i'm a hot
dog
my chest my bust size and his waist but
i don't know
well abe what did he tell you you just
tell me that there's no way these
measurements make sense we did it like
three times
i was like yeah dude my body's an
anomaly
he's like most of the time when wipes do
it they do it wrong and i was like well
his wife owns a clothing brand i think
she knows what she's doing he goes
something he goes something's not right
here and he's like come in and talk to
me
and then i then i went in and then uh
yeah he kept asking me questions he
asked me
he said i don't mean to be disrespectful
i'm sure he's a very nice guy he goes
but does he have
a quick butt a big ass i do have a big
ass what did you tell
this i i said you're juicy
you said that it's true well you're fat
you're fat baby no but he was saying
that it doesn't it doesn't make sense he
goes because
yeah i don't know that guy he's gonna
get frustrated with me
well you know it's funny because well i
started wondering did we make a mistake
but when i got the clothes they fit me
so i don't think so
but you got to appreciate that my body
is so grotesque and
anomalies that the taylor was like in
all of my years in the shemalta business
what does that i said that right then
right which
malta business it's schmidt it's the
clothing business
i don't know what they call that it's
old people [ __ ] right zach you know
schmalter
oh yeah i thought you were saying
like schmaltz which is like you know
what is it zach schmata
an old rag i just read it on google
apparently
and all my time in the shema
someone's outfit
like this i just put it on
that's according to google that's what
you meant to say
no but people say that the shema anyway
whatever people don't care
but the point is that this taylor was so
perplexed by my proportions
when i show him a video of you he's like
yeah he's not as big at all as
what the measurements are describing so
i get we i think we there was something
off when we did it the first time
but when we got it it'll fit you good
that'd be fine like i'm not proud of the
fact that i have a [ __ ] up
game i have like a [ __ ] up gamer body
where i'm like fat and skinny at the
same time
you know that i've always been like that
my whole life it's called gamer body
gamer body syndrome fat and skinny at
this you're
a fat fat fatty
i'm working hard though to lose weight
even though i look really fat today
because i just shaved i've got a big
round egg
[ __ ] face i think it's just you're
not used to seeing yourself shaved
probably yeah whatever needed to get
done
anyway that's the tux story
dan i don't know much about the pog
champ uh emoji being erased
wait can we talk about um the background
oh sure what do you want to say about it
just uh
a new background everyone's commenting
about it
oh really so a b i mean a b did it he's
our he's our designer
he's our set designer we talk about abs
setting right now yeah why are you in
the bahamas bro are you super spreading
with the demilio family
this is uh no it's 2021 ab usually
i was a nervous wreck during these
friday episodes but you were
what i i don't know i'm chilling though
this year i'm good
i'm give background sound off
background sound yeah you don't have any
you're not going to be opening browsers
you know computer muted okay we're all
good
you're taking it easy huh can we i'll
take it too easy
can we expect uh no random
commercials be played during the show
that was the joke i tried to make that
apparently didn't make sense
yeah oh you kidding huh but anyway abe
did this and um you know because we had
the christmas decorating up it looks
good
i like it i'm impressed yeah you know
just some art
like i mean what do you guys think
you know they love it and we love it
i love it okay so i don't know
apparently it's a big story the pog
champ emoji on twitch
i always see this emoji i don't know
what the [ __ ] it was
but the who is the pog champ what is a
pog
it's actually in reference to paw you
remember pogs from the 90s
yeah yeah yeah this guy played pogs in a
video
at one point a lot of people say it
stands for
play of game as well but i looked into
it
yeah i looked into it a little bit in it
i think the pog origin really is pogs
there's a video of him playing pogs
he just had an epic pog slam uh yeah
and um and so it just became an
extremely popular emote on twitch
uh but yeah this dude um i guess is
pretty mega now
and so they decided to pull the plug on
really so
if people were using the pog champ emoji
does that mean they had to subscribe to
his
twitch no it was one it was actually one
of the universal
twitch emotes okay that's what you
adopted it is like you could use
you know as any any uh stream you can so
they just dropped this guy
face is just banned well wait what did
he do
it's just his face being it's that tweet
that's on screen that
they pulled it oh this is the pog champ
that's the same guy yeah okay
i feel like i saw that let's see will
there be civil unrest for the women who
were executed inside the capital today
or will the mag of martyr oh no
not the mega martyr yeah this field will
be aired soon
i love it on band.com video and the
resistance stop video and it sounds
pretty gruesome
i feel like there's no relation between
the actual
guy and the pogba it seems pretty
overkill also how does this guy
i don't think anybody even knows who he
is at this point like the vast majority
of people that use it had no idea who he
was so
interesting the twitch was like [ __ ]
this guy he's not the bog champ anymore
how do you go from being damn dude the
mag of gold can get
anyone you go from playing from playing
pog
to storming the capital [ __ ]
extremism can hit anywhere
i saw the video that the so-called mega
martyr and that girl was
well whatever i won't talk about it but
she ah whatever
whatever none of my business
you know well recipes pogchamp i was
saying we should make our own pog champ
emoji for
our lives you know do it right now
it's something about his lips curling so
much i don't know how to do that
face camera a little bit more yeah
that's pretty good
open your mouth wider though
where's he looking he's looking like
over he's like off to the side
away from the camera yeah
that's that's pretty that's pretty good
i'm not gonna lie
okay good there we go
somebody clip that and send it in i'll
add it make that happen y'all
um recipes pogchamp you know oh the re
we have the original pog champ video
let's
just take this people saying he didn't
play pogs what are you talking about dan
i mean look it up but i just looked it
up last night because i was curious
well here's the origin i mean let's find
out right now there's no point in
debating
right this is the origin of the face the
links are all
in the description six million views
just for the blog champ
he's good x
okay i'm sorry now let's go let's go
[Music]
now we're good we're good just cause he
bumped the camera
the whole pogba is phenomenal from this
it's just that
wait so so what's the deal with poggers
then
does anybody know because dan cause that
guy i'm telling you that guy
plays here i'll send you the link to him
playing pogba no one believes
dan yeah nobody believes you man just go
it's on know your meme
uh if you go to pogchamp here here's the
video well
i get it no your meme is quite reputable
yeah
i mean those [ __ ] don't ever miss
what is this one that everyone's doing
here i just sent you the video looks
like we have one of our own
oh with the cowboy hat yeah so wait that
actually is pretty close to cowboy
this one damn yeah this is a video
i'm playing pog yeah okay i'm bored
what years this from 2011 okay that
makes sense
i haven't played pog in like 30 [ __ ]
years i got it
why don't we play with my ancient pogs
collection do you guys like gamers or
something
neato gutex man how did you become part
of the magical
dog yeah you're just playing pogs with
your homie
so mike and next thing you know you're
going to prison for stealing nancy
pelosi's
laptop i'm the best she's crazy
we'll see about that
yeah okay so he played pog once in a
video after a gaff
does that make him the pog champ i i
mean i don't know
does anyone know does anybody else have
an alternate explanation for what
pogchamp is well if it's not know your
meme i trust it
i really do oh [ __ ] you
is going i trust dan
okay ela's doing some deep research in
the meantime
it's just google i wanted to send some
love to um
mr beast for doing a rewinding including
yours truly what's up youtube you know
i think we can all agree that 2020 might
be the only thing
in existence worse than 2018 rewind
i love 2018 read by i i have to yeah
i have to defend 2018 rewind and i
i know it's just such a shame that like
it was so bad and it became so iconic
that now they're not
making it anymore and they're depriving
us of these incredible memes
pandemic thousands of creators just
couldn't make videos
it was brutal and i can't blame youtube
for not wanting to make a rewind
but a lot of good things still did
happen this year and let's be honest it
just wouldn't be youtube if we didn't
have a rewind to make fun of so
enjoy ah wait you have the sound you
have the will smith
ready okay good all right here we go
that's me i saw myself
wait let me go back for tonight
go ahead zach with the soundbites you
know why we're here
fortnite
[Music]
i'm watching the new rewind i'm trying
to give it a good sound
who wants to listen to music
fortnite fortnite
is rewinding it's rewind time fortnite
k-pop uh you don't want me man
hey whoa that's not for everyone you
don't want me man
[Music]
oh dude yeah he's gonna be in jail soon
because
i heard that he's the one that stole
nancy pelosi's podium
really james charles stole nancy's wait
so now you heard it i thought you were
just asking questions
i heard it from a voice in my head
oh no it wasn't me though
oh no ah minecraft this is challenging
hello fortnight anyway
we could go on and on you guys want more
of this no
ah nope
that people have headphones on their
heads well
isn't it like don't we have um
we have compression you're still
screaming
but we got it not magic the compression
yes it is
okay yeah it is magic four
fortnight look at these super spreaders
we love our super spreaders
we love our super spreaders
for tonight
so we were in youtube rewind thank you
mr beast epic
we made it oh they showed a clip of me
picking my nose or something
in the for here watch this
you see that like why would you that was
your nose
here it's coming up why have all the
shots and all the video if you're just
gonna show me for like
one millisecond
there i missed it okay let me slow it
down like a billion times
you know what i mean why grab the one
where i'm like picking my nose man
this might take a while
oh not really picking your nose
it's like did they even
what do we think inappropriate
is rewind time all right it's a two hour
podcast you could put
any frames that's my point damn fingers
in your nose
that's my point ah i think foreign
mr beast personally hates you fortnight
ah it's a nice shot of uh it's rewind
time yeah of course they're obviously
looking at ela not me when they
you know what i mean they're like oh she
looks good that's a good job
i have a pretty fun segment here it kind
of breaks one of our rules but i think
it
ten it treads more into the territory of
fun than
than like serious like we have a a whole
mega compilation of covet super
spreaders of
influencers it's not serious it's just
fun because they're idiots
right so it does break our cardinals one
of our partners
although we continually break all the
rules
hey what are rules meant it's not to be
broken bro
no it's fun it's goofy
forget
do we have any messages or calls before
i get into this what was that from
trisha
has anyone actually died from corona no
nobody uh i've got the
pogba emo put in oh already
let me see that [ __ ] spamming it how do
you do it uh h3 pogchamp
are you [ __ ] how'd you what the heck
you cut that in already oh this well
somebody
ian sent it to me oh that's pretty good
actually that was
fun wait doesn't his face the other way
or no i flipped it i sent it to damn
with flipped
did you see it you put it in the wrong
way dan i i just
you only sent me one no check your dms
check your name or if it's facing the
wrong way
flip it flip horizontal why'd you send
it in a different place
how about that i sent it to your dms hey
dan
to a different place and then what did
that mean somewhere else
it's already in the discord i made it i
put it in i sent it to you you had one
job
right and why did you i hope dan is
gonna be okay
why don't you send him one looking up
too while you're at it yeah why not and
down
for all the cardinal direction he's just
supposed to click the right one and
guess
i mean thank you dan
okay i just uh i replaced it okay we've
got the new corrected poggers champ h3
pogba i'm waiting to see it
get excited everybody's gonna flip it
once oh they're all right
and good luck they're all left come on
flip it come on come on
let's go in the chat let's flip it right
that looks pretty good i'm not even
gonna hate it
that's pretty good that's okay that's
not bad
what why are you hating okay dan that's
not bad huh so
i mean these are pretty good these are
all like really fun to celebrate
so and james charles of course is in
this who we are asking
serious we have serious questions of if
he was inside the capitol building
oh no
james charles i'm saying there was a lot
of people who have not been identified
and i and it's possible if he can't if
he didn't have a good alibi that he was
in there pog champs in the chat holy
[ __ ]
all right covet welcome to our new
segment covet super spreaders
first up little pump how did libel
little pump became kind of became kind
of a mega
oh is that what it is he just wants to
be like kanye but he
he actually went in way deeper than
kanye i think
i suppose that true kanye ran against
trump didn't he so he wasn't
because now that means being a like a
mega martyr
anyway rapper lil pump oh he changed his
name to lil pimp because that's what
donald called him
he misintroduced him right as little
pimp so now he is actually going by lil
pimp
[Laughter]
he says he's not wearing a mask in 2021
ever
and that covet is fake oh nice
all 20 20 21 i ain't wearing no masks i
don't got to wear no [ __ ] masks [ __ ]
corona's fake
playing cards all 22 interesting take
he also got kicked off so then following
him
is there a video of him getting kicked
off or is it like i'd like to see that
story
so following his pledge
all right just [ __ ] jeff blue [ __ ]
everybody
y'all [ __ ] some bombs all
20 20 21 i ain't wearing no man is there
more
info about him getting kicked off
jetblue so yeah he pledged not to wear a
mask and then jet
and then you know later on he tries to
fly on an airplane without a mask and
they're like
nah dude you cannot fly without a mask
so it turns out
she's such a prophet cardi b yeah
it's true she was right she was
screaming corona buyers before anyone
gave a
[ __ ] about it said [ __ ] was getting real
dude i'm i'm not i don't wanna i'll just
be straight up
i am scared that we are not moving fast
enough on the vaccination
and this [ __ ] is gonna mutate
before we all get vaccinated
mm-hmm and take it from me i'm was i've
always been right about cold
but this is after dark i know i'm just
saying it was in my mind not very
light-hearted
just saying you should be scared you
should be frightened you should
definitely be anxious right now i'm
worried about covet okay next
it's a good thing that okay next jake
paul continues to be the biggest
[ __ ] idiot in the world
don't care winner of our cove idiot uh
prize
yeah yeah am i right about that yeah no
he won for sure
and and well deserved oh man
he is in ohio oh i gotta mute that
he's in ohio there's not a single mask
in sight
ohio ohio state lit boys
yeah this is just from the 20 it's like
a week old
wow you know 4 000 deaths
yesterday over 4 000 deaths yesterday
stay lit e state litty not really
i don't know how many people need to die
a day before people start caring about
it you know what i mean
it's crazy four thousand a day let's
[ __ ]
we're too deep in the denial i don't
know i feel like
people are not gonna change their mind
now you think so
maybe because they're gonna look so
stupid so
also apparently he's moving to miami so
he can just not
apparently in florida they don't give a
[ __ ] about covid because their governor
there's an absolute [ __ ] psychopath
uh jake here trailer put on one of the
biggest
events of the year it was historic
and i just can't wait for what's to come
stay tuned
and uh look it relocated baby brother
put on one of the
what
yeah jake does have florida energy
someone pointed out he's definitely in
florida
he he he belongs in florida not in l.a
yeah
yeah gp coming at you and his dad too
i mean his dad will fit him right
perfectly there his dad has more like
alabama what's the age of consent in
florida can you tell me
because i'm just looking out for jesus
be wrong then be muffled
and be wrong because if gp can hit up 60
it's actually 18.
yeah again alabama is probably
friendlier
so is that alabama borders florida
uh alabama 16 just looked it up okay
good so we can take a trip to alabama
i cannot believe you could [ __ ] a
sixteen-year-old legally in the united
states
uh 16 and 16 is the lowest
so that that is that's as low as it goes
so gp you know
that's great i i don't know of a state
near california
that close where you can have sex with a
16 year old so gp and maybe even jake
paul will be having a good time there
i'm curious what states actually uh in
usa
nevada don't say it
lowest age of consent in usa
is there is there one state that's
okay let's see now i'm just interested
highest and lower nevada is 16 according
to google
yeah the lowest age you can send the
united states is 16.
by the way i'm totally fine with the age
of consent being 16 if there's like a
caveat where
they get like two or three year
difference or something you know yeah
but like for gp to come and [ __ ] a 16
year old is not okay
they actually have a lot it's called
like the it's called like the romeo and
juliet law
where it's like if you're within three
years it's not statutory rape
right yeah but guys uh this is for uh
greg paul alabama alaska arkansas
connecticut district of columbia
interesting
georgia hawaii in the god damn there's a
lot of states i can't even read all
these
talk to me baby bendy then
not appropriate oh you ready to get
really creeped out the age of consent in
nigeria
guess it this is the lowest in the world
that's someone just typed it 11. it's
11.
it's 12 in philippines and angola canada
is 16 someone wrote wait in japan the
age of consent is 13 you guys
whoa that's weird hey coming off of this
really dark conversation uh we're at 30
minutes
um i don't know if you want give a
buffer before uh
you know what uh you know what kids
[Laughter]
you don't want to do it i'm right there
we need to change the subject first
before we segue into the ad please
right there it's on the edge of my
tongue swallow it
oh man all right let's watch here let's
let's look at james charles
cleanse the palette thank you and then
we can do the add raid and then you guys
will get my joke
okay so james shaw i hate this video so
much content a lot
away from each other follow all cdc
guidelines stare at the camera and smile
and still make an unfathomable amount of
money
but instead they do [ __ ] like this and
can't just sit their asses at home as if
la isn't the epicenter for a coronavirus
right now i can't really focus can i
have the actual video like that why does
everybody have to do that with the
headphone microphone
it's a tick tock sounds like [ __ ] stop
doing that
that is so true that is so true wait let
me find his actual tick tock so i'm so
listen so here he did like
makes me so angry he's such a [ __ ]
douchebag
okay cool so here he is this is like the
whole family
the mom is right here you know in l.a
they're literally turning away people
with heart attacks and strokes because
the hospitals have
zero percent
availability what is this crap somebody
died
somebody died what the [ __ ] oh sister it
has like 30 million views
why 14 million likes it's supposed to be
a parody of mean girls okay yeah i mean
i mean if that helps explain it
whatsoever i'll give a [ __ ] if it's a
reference to the [ __ ]
moby dick you know what i mean it gives
you [ __ ]
um you know
there's someone dying every eight
minutes in la and then meanwhile you got
james charles who thinks that the world
doesn't apply to him
you're really sad no you're not you're
lying it keeps denying everything
but because he hasn't left his house or
something i don't know
right you're posting videos that say
otherwise
nice house by the way
you know this guy doesn't give a [ __ ]
whoever this is i think it's a larry
he's like on his phone he's like i don't
give a [ __ ] bro
oh you're right he's literally just
standing there
it's like can you try a little harder
bro wait he's
he's dancing but then he's over it he
gave up wait i got a text
does that make sense this is why i think
like the demilio sisters despite
everything are still really young
and then you've got their their parents
i feel like are the biggest clown
goblins in the world because
they're willing
to be absolute [ __ ] bags they apparently
have like a reality show coming out in
hulu like they're trying to be the new
kardashians
[Music]
could not give any less [ __ ] about her
family i mean
they already are so low what's the uh
their their family has a lot of money
right like what what do their parents do
like
i mean i think they're rich from their
celebrity
or their father is a politician okay no
former
he's not he used to be like a mega
politician
really really he's mega they got a lot
of [ __ ] for that
huh former paul wow sister
former politician usually means lobbyist
is what i'm guessing i don't think he
was like a high-ranking politician or
anything i'm reading that he worked in
sportswear
and the mom was a model and personal
trainer
yeah i think they just got super rich
from their
newfound success gotcha yeah
and so they're riding this train all the
way to super spreaderville
let's get glam let's get glam oh this
one has 70 million views brad
[Laughter]
here's another one i made the same day
sister
dude it's like do you have no shame man
just
like don't post videos like this man
it's just so
it's just so embarrassing bro just have
some shame
you know [ __ ] it's
awful it's just awful if you want to see
something really awful you'll just watch
this
stop oh no oh my god
yeah that one has 30 million
so this this [ __ ] is crazy bro this guy
is out of his mind
i can't do that i can't i can't
that is so true what is happening
dude can we just watch james charles
tick tock no we should do this
would you tap that zack
oh what no i don't know we're just
wondering where your boundary is
[Laughter]
all right me undies let me get the copy
we love me on this only either
i love me undies is the only undies
in the game that i i like james charles
have a voluptuous ass
[Applause]
and frankly if you've heard anything
from this taylor my proportions are so
ungodly so unnatural
everything fits me tight especially
underwear
so when it comes to soft beautiful
underwear there's nothing
like me undies in the game
breathes it's soft
it's fun forget about it
you know and let's face it when was the
last time you refreshed your underwear
drawer i've care i
back in college used to carry around my
underwear for years until there was
literal
just it was eviscerated it was
do you know that i've well i've seen
yours like that
i feel like even myself i don't know why
underwear is like something you don't
think about never throw out yeah
my dude mine were getting so old that
waistband was getting like crusty it's
weird like it was just disintegrating
it's just and so you know that's when i
knew i had made it in life when i could
buy my own underwear kind of i was like
ah [ __ ] yeah
and that's what me andy's is you can
make it in life
you got to step up your comfy game in
2021.
uh now this dark at 4pm all you want to
do is become one with the couch meundies
gets that and that's why they want to
help you step up your cozy game
their loungewear and undies are super
soft and come in everything from classic
to adventurous prints
they're literally made for your couch
and guess what you don't ever have to
leave that couch again with me andy's
membership
a subscription that sends new pairs
right to your door with site-wide
savings and exclusive sales you'll
automatically pay less for everything
me undies has a great offer for our
listeners for any first-time purchase
you get fifteen percent off and
free shipping mendes also has their
problem free philosophy if you are not
satisfied with any product for any
reason they'll refund
or exchange it no caveats no questions
asked
and definitely no sniffing of your used
undies at the uh fulfillment center so
to get 50
off your first order and free shipping
go to meundies.com
h3 that's meundies.com h3
thank you to them ab do you want to read
any donations
they all kind of cleared to me no
yeah i have some um
so carly for ten dollars is feeling old
turning 26 today
what has been the favorite age so far
haven't missed a podcast in two years
sending love from new york
wow say what our favorite episode your
favorite age
oh my favorite age sorry it was like
i zoned out i wasn't here
i was looking at the document my
favorite piece
no she you want to read it again not
that
she said favorite age right she just
turned
26 okay that's been our favorite age and
it's a good day you've been watching us
for two years
thank you it's a good age
congratulations
i love you what was my favorite age hmm
i kind of do think 26 is like the best
27.
i honestly don't have a favorite age i'm
not too mad at being my current age
it's a nice age
i don't like that thank you i wish i was
that age again yeah
you have a favorite age anybody else is
that something people think about
um i feel like that's something i'll
think about when i'm like 70.
i i just i don't know i feel like after
you get past 25 it's kind of a blur
that's true i can't really differentiate
after that point
i mean my my young age my young 20s was
kind of
horrible because i had untreated anxiety
disorder so
i don't think back and think oh that was
the great times i was actually miserable
so
it's hard for me to say but thank you i
had a lot of fun at that age i would
probably say like 21
22. um yeah 21 was great
[Laughter]
um okay so isabella for five dollars
said i was coming down from shrooms on
new year's eve and your podcast was the
only thing that didn't make my brain
explode
thank you thank you thank you thank you
that's nice ready for ten dollars the
show would would stress me the [ __ ] out
true oh yeah i'm gonna watch it
but i mean i guess she just feels
comfortable with us so that's nice
there's a chaotic energy to this that i
don't think i would vibe well with
do you think even looking at the
backgrounds i think it might trip
someone out
well now yeah now we just we literally
lost all of our
trippers all five people tripping balls
watching the show
and they turned the channel thanks guys
maddie for ten dollars said as a
floridian everyone is acting like
nothing is happening but people keep
saying things like
once all this is over love it here
right that's interesting
yep someone asked
how's the ps5 going ps5 is amazing i
have to
have to thank trisha for getting that
there is a conspiracy theory within our
crew that she bought it on stockx
i hope that's not true though oh my god
but i believe her i wouldn't i'm not
gonna call her i believe i don't think
so because i feel like it would have
taken
longer to arrive you think so
i believe her i believe her because
that's what she told me
nice that's the policy it's been great i
played um
demon souls beat it crushed it owned it
easy
it was actually easy really was kind of
just a baller like that
oh my god and i went back and i'm
playing now
dark souls 1 which is fine but it's
really annoying it's just i'm just
irritated playing it so i don't know the
dark
the dark games the demon or dark souls
souls games they're so annoying they go
demon souls dark souls it's like make up
your [ __ ] mind first of all
and every game is literally just the
same [ __ ] game like oh my god make a
new game
like how do people keep playing every i
get their fun games
and i really think that demon souls was
a really beautiful fun game
but dark souls starts the same exact way
you're in a castle and there's dragons
and you gotta do
it's like oh guys mate come on use your
brain start something else
it's like every game is literally a
carbon copy of the next
oh my god you know what i mean i can't
even watch you play
those games don't interest me at all no
you're not an elite child but i have
been playing too
i'm playing katamari on switch oh [ __ ]
that's probably the more
that's yeah that's the real [ __ ] i wish
i was playing ketamari
my girlfriend was just playing but i'm
stuck in the catacombs i'm stuck in the
catacombs with some [ __ ] dumbass
skeletons
it's just so annoying stupid
[Music]
tyga went to miami to throw a party
packed oh my gosh shoulder to shoulder
not a single mask in sight
what's so hard to understand i mean
shouldn't this be criminal
like i mean okay just
dude look at this idiot he's like yeah
what's up
ain't no pain damn it here ain't no
panty damn here
by the way they're not even looking like
they're having fun look at these people
they're just standing there like bruh
look how i'm not fun they're having you
guys actually like to go to a club
i was gonna say that's just normal
people think it's so fun to go to a club
right
and it's all we're gonna have a crazy
night it's gonna be so much fun this is
what it's actually like look at them
did you call it a panty danny yeah i did
like a panty manny
like dude these people are not even
having fun they're going there and
getting
spreading covet and not even having fun
doing it these people
these are these people at least they're
keeping this
who's keeping up these people they're
like we'll do it and only if we can be
elevated
by at least 12 feet
yo can somebody tell what the [ __ ] is
this like bra
[Laughter]
man clubs are weird
yeah you just stand in a room with a
bunch of people while
some other weirdos twirl from the
ceiling
what is this [ __ ] cirque du soleil or
goddamn club what the hell
bruh you just don't get it i don't get
clubs they have people
in like cages like dancing and [ __ ] it's
like okay
cool dude okay boomer
my boomer you enjoyed the club
what's that would you enjoy this uh no
i've never been a fan of clubs rock
clubs yeah but not like
what am i supposed to do with these
people twirling on the ceiling what am i
supposed to do with this
am i supposed to watch nothing am i
supposed to ignore it's like
do i glance and then forget it's like a
decoration
there's people twirling on the [ __ ]
ceiling part of the vibe
what am i supposed to do with this man
oh my god
okay or you do like this and then you
just ignore them
like isn't it weird to be twirling on
the ceiling and nobody's even paying
attention to you you're like i'm
twirling on the scene
[Music]
maybe i'm a boomer i don't know
tige is having a lot of fun here you can
tell these guys
spend like a million dollars on these
parties just so they can have sex it's
like bro really
okay boomer you can find a cheaper date
you know especially after from trisha
what girls do to get you pregnant
that was a crazy revelation oh my god
she said that she lies she used to lie
about being on birth control and that a
lot of girls do that
yeah i i don't know about that i don't
know i've always wanted to
tell that what my mom always my parents
always told me that growing up
well girls do that i'm sure i'm sure
there are people that do it but like
if i would assume that the people that
says a lot of girls do that she's
talking about
in her world of l.a
gotcha social climbing
look at drake's baby mama she's she's
set for life
no glove no love what does that mean no
glove nope
no condom no
no glove no love girl
[ __ ]
that's crazy man i gotta i gotta have
like a really long talk with theodore
about
all this when he's older well people are
in the chat are saying they know girls
who do that so
how is that real i mean that's just so
crazy
i'm so shocked that there actually is
like um i'm shocked
they lie about being on birth control
why do you want i mean
what kind of life is that i've also i've
also heard of like because a lot of
girls get irritable
from uh different kinds of condoms so
they they lie about it because of that
as well
no nobody lies because the condom
irritates them bro
well they don't think they're going to
get pregnant i think there's a lot of
false information too about
how easy it is to get pregnant so i
think they think it's not a big deal
like no one's no one's ever scared a
pre-cum like whenever you said on the
episode i'm like you're like the first
other person i've ever heard talk about
it besides myself it's not even
and like i said it's not even that it's
like you gotta pull out in time like
right i mean the pull out and pray
method doesn't work
it does not work pulling out is for
[ __ ]
idiots that i have heard of so many
people
who do like that's their method and
that's
i'm all that's how it is and that's how
you see we meet people with like eight
kids by like five different women
like i pull out yeah that surprised me
i pull out dude that's all good
my last roommate people that go have sex
with their
their their contraceptive plan is to
pull out
have they have kids they end up on mari
you know what i mean no glove no love
there you go zach take it from zach boys
right ian i mean
there's a couple people saying that it
sounds like a fake narrative that's kind
of misogynistic
and that that was my hey i'm with you
dude i don't believe it sounds like to
me too
bro i'm with you i don't think women do
that at least i don't take it i think if
but i mean the women that i'm attracted
i think like the women that i would
generally with aren't
type of women to do that yeah
like i said i don't know a single person
personally that would do something like
that it's crazy
right yeah i think it's a very small
majority but it's just such a big thing
to risk
you know such a yeah i'm not taking any
chances
but yeah no i definitely i don't think
it's yeah i think it's a very
i guess if you're rich though and you're
out there you got to be careful
luckily i never had to deal with that
problem
i only ever had sex when i was broke and
people were desperate not to have a baby
with me when i was having sex
you know what i mean
girls squirt spermicide up there after i
have sex with them
um they say a lot of people
uh in the chat that they do know people
yeah
so this is the thing crazy how could you
do that
yeah and i feel like people are [ __ ]
up how could you do that like it's such
a big deal to have a baby
i honestly if i had a female friend who
i know trisha told me that and she's
with moses now and stuff but i was kind
of if i had a female friend who was
actively doing that i would not
be friends with them that is just
beyond insane and [ __ ] up
papa john be careful out there bro he's
out there dating but now papa john i'd
not in papa john
hopefully he's protecting himself
i'm carrying up though is what
yeah because that's marrying up he's got
that
he's got that billionaire money yeah i'm
saying i'd nutting him right easily i
won't even i wouldn't even pull it out i
got it
yeah i get it how many papa john's are
out there you know what i mean
like who wants to like who wants to
[ __ ] have like someone like
no offense but like no offense zach but
like
you're not look at that face
what are you trying to say i'm just
saying like i got like there's not many
papa john billionaires out there who was
like they have golden nut
are you saying my nuts not golden
[Laughter]
yeah you're the golden boy but you have
bronze nut fair enough
you gotta have the papa guac yeah yeah
you got to be like a
multi-multi-millionaire
to have that papa jizz that's papa john
butter sauce you know what i mean
um important question when is the next
bachelor
or bachelorette what am i [ __ ] chris
hanson
oh you mean the h3 bachelorette great
bachelor i don't know we have to find a
good candidate
yeah i think you mean chris harrison
chris harrison chris yeah ethan always
confuses them
[Music]
i'll just be your secret lover d'angelo
wallace just put out a video criticizing
frenemies who's that
his name is throw it on we got
i know him it's going to be a long video
we got beef boys let's [ __ ] throw it
up
throw it out i'm watching it in the
other window it's only time
oh by the way there is photographic
evidence of of james charles
oh no oh look at the beanie being in the
uh
of course this is cam grant
somebody send this to the fbi please
i know they're looking for tips
who is this guy that's talking [ __ ] i
don't know um i recognize the name
oh this is the guy that made like the
20-year the two
backfired no way oh this is the guy who
made
the video about the challenge
shane dawson right why did all these
shame with
headphones what is this just like the
you know let me see drama youtuber
oh wait no wait what is this is this not
the guy who made the documentary about
shane
he made it he made a shane video it has
16 million views yeah
well he made like the cancel shane
wow starting a podcast with trisha
paytas backfired how did it backfire
okay here we go we ready to do this ian
can you just tell us what's going
on yeah we going to war seems like we're
going to war
i'm not ready for this yeah maybe just
just give me time stamps for them to
watch this whole [ __ ] thing live but
i have no sound then
[Music]
is chocolate rain
[ __ ] has a baritone people like
him in the chat
and yeah i've always liked the angelo
people like him yeah well we're going to
war
he's apparently made a video talking
[ __ ] about friendly so what are we
supposed to do
i mean you guys like him and and he said
what am i supposed to do i mean i don't
know what he said yet
i disagree that it backfired though
conflict of interest here
oh maybe he should let me just read the
comments trisha is saying jewish people
are so different
oh maybe he's just he's just pulling the
uh
baby yeah all right thank you
and just watching so i mean what's the
deal oh you're saying to watch it
well i'm only halfway to 2020. let's see
let's give it a shot
i'm not ready for bad news i don't think
he's going he can't what is he gonna say
i can't get enough of his voice about
this podcast because i've actually
watched this i actually love this ball
good
everyone he's saying he's great and they
love him
what can i do what can i do i've got the
foot soldiers say i'm wearing a pickle
here we're in a bind
we love him but yet okay let me watch it
before i before i decide this war
you know you know what after him
with the lawsuit what what he made a
video exposing shannon lester he was
like the first one to do it and then
she threatened him with the lawsuit
who's shannon lester
shall and lester um voices of the past
some of you may have already guessed
i'll tell you all a lot off
so i'm going to talk about it all the
good the bad and the ugly but of course
before that i'd like to read my comment
shout out from my last video
okay but let's get the comment shout out
for her intensity this voice is amazing
everyone from the trans community people
with d i think he's just talking about
her all the crazy [ __ ] she said
and then the other person in this
equation is ethan klein
one of the youtubers behind the hugely
popular channel h3h3 productions
which he ran with his wife and their
conflict is that
for some reason they decided to start a
weekly podcast
despite their completely clashing
personalities and their rocky history
and to top it all off
trisha is dating worse than that
brother she's a gay it's a mess but
before i emphasize that let's unpack
today's sponsor today's video
let's not a bad [ __ ] they got to
pay me to watch your video
audible
plus when friends and influence people
by deal
oh please everybody recommends that book
i don't want friends and
oh i well it's a great book yeah but
that's what everybody says get a [ __ ]
read a book
it's a great book okay i like him i'm
not going to war it's a great one
i like the headphones people want it so
far we're in the good
we like him look we like him we're not
going to war yet
one of the only reasons this podcast
works and i have to go over there
he said it works okay good see we're
friends okay
it's not funny 30-day trial today let's
get back to the video so first i really
do want to go over what i think is good
about this podcast
because um surprise of all surprises
it's not 100 percent terrible one of the
only oh
please clearly people like it
please i love you we're friends we all
love you let's just just watch
people say okay i'm not gonna do this
and i've been able to get through it is
because trisha paytas
is actually i did a real self on this
podcast she's not
this extremely fake dramatic well she is
that's literally her real self and she
basically admits it i think it's safe to
say i'm the most dramatic i try to start
beef with everybody yeah she goes into
detail about how
a lot of her previous videos have been
for attention as well and it's like i'm
not congratulating her for doing the
bare minimum
but i do find it a refreshing change of
pace another strong point is that trisha
is extremely funny on this podcast i
agree because
she is it's funny she's i'm not getting
this to be cute no one thinks you
like we actually don't need it what do
you mean that we don't need gravity
what if it was never going to be better
i still don't know if you can see on the
other hand there's some things i didn't
expect from christopher payton this year
she's actually very open about a lot of
her real struggles
i see it he said he went to therapy this
year so hopefully that helped because it
helped me like if you're always on the
defense like i was always
trisha is such a lightning rod it's
crazy how
she really is prolific you know yeah
i'm still learning who trisha is i don't
even know what's the right way to
describe her
but she's such an entertainer too
on top of everything like he said she's
really funny
oh my god somebody in the chat says um
he he sided with you and was defending
you during the uh
james charles hoodie debacle oh i love
him he's my favorite creator
here i'm gonna throw a like on it i knew
i liked him
i knew i liked him i knew i loved
d'angelo wallace right guys
right guys i mean dan was the one
immediately dan was like we're going to
war
we're so we're going to damn was like
we're going to storm the capital hold on
i'm
muting your mic dan dan was like
we're going to storm the capital all i
said is all these dramas
[Music]
i was just making an observation i love
deangelo
he's the man i love d'angelo wallace and
my favorite creator
all the producers have the same sony
headphones
thanks dan by the way if you guys want
to go to d'angelo wallace see on wiki
feet let's go give him five star
let's give him the foot soldier bomb
give him a bump
wait who is this zach is just mad
because he got put on the same day and
he's like angela wallace i know i just
don't care
number two i don't even care what that's
not him
i want to smell feet does he not have a
wicked feet
oh brother i'm here i'm i'm trying to
give you the wiki feed bump
well we love him we love you angelo like
it's just more because you're like
broken and you don't get hurt besides
being open about
her experience with therapy and the
various mental issues that she
goes through she talks a lot about
experiences that she's had that she's
never opened up before
yeah i know overdose on february 5th of
2019 that's not a mental hospital
because i was trying to kill myself i
know a lot about trisha paytas
and um i had to quote a tweet all of it
is against my will
but i have to say i never knew that she
was going through quite this much
now she's not the only person this
podcast is called [ __ ] and i have a lot
to say about ethan
as well first of all ethan is actually
even funnier than trisha you like how
you mix your head look dude he's the
best guy
well you know we love dan you know i've
always been a huge fan of d'angelo
wallace
i've said it from the beginning for a
long time because it makes me look like
i'm trying to do it
um pictures of his feet yeah i think he
i think he actually avoids it like oh
smart man
yeah well let me just offer the olive
branch d'angelo if you're watching this
get some take some pictures of your feet
it will always
everything ends up on wikifeed and we'll
give you the bump
you know that's a standing offer you had
like a birth defect or something
i don't i don't know why people being
mean to each other
is funny but i still laughed obviously
what's more important
than that though is that he's
surprisingly cognizant of trisha's
mental problems that she goes through on
the show you know sometimes when she
starts getting really bad which oh she
does we're gonna get to that in a second
i noticed that he doesn't push her a lot
of times he tries to stop her
i am doing it the most hold on hold on
hold on hold on just slow down you seem
really
caustic today and he doesn't just
abandon trisha paytas like i think most
people do when they come to the
conclusion that
it's kind of difficult to handle her but
yeah i mean you know thank you we love
this man
thank you ela i love frenemies what can
i say i agree i think it's just it's
phenomenal it's like
it's like you take you take uh they're
saying d'angelo for bachelor
how do i know that he's not that he's
single you want the
angel if you're watching this you want
to be the bachelor contact me okay let
me follow my 100
success rate yeah i mean dude 100
true love success rate hold on someone
is saying he's married
he's married this is all
i they're all super random comments
there's not much
you don't want me man i can't
spend an entire video saying good things
about something that would be
insane so next i'm going to talk about
the bad parts of the frenemies podcast
first of all
trisha paytas crosses the line so
far trisha pages pole vaults over the
line
at least once per episode one thing that
she loves to do for some reason is
attack
ethan's wife trisha on and on about how
elo secretly hates her she is constantly
putting words
in her mouth doesn't like me
i think at first her dislike for ethan's
wife was kind of
funny or at least they tried to play it
off as a joke but it got
just weirdly real when during an
argument trista storms out and calls her
the sea roar i literally don't care
literally i don't want to come back and
i really hate her if that's not bad
enough she also
routinely brings up off-limits things to
make ethan feel like
dirt basically randomly bringing up the
fact that he had a pill addiction that
he had to overcome he also just
repeatedly claims that ethan wants to
cheat on
his wife with her she goes as soon as
she is to insult her
i totally just brush past that because
i'm like
i don't take it seriously because i so
don't i'm just i can't i don't know how
to convince trisha that i don't want to
have sex with her but i really don't
she's just not my type sorry
my type is
is a beautiful israeli
when you have a kid you should try and
be with that as much as possible not
be with the strangers yeah nothing says
bad parenting to me
like making sure that your child is
being watched
while you make money to provide a nice
life for them right
i love this guy anything that she does
on this podcast which i personally just
find
so hard to watch i'm not gonna say
anti-semitic
wondering yeah i mean we're in so deep
it's like like
fetishizing that true yeah trisha goes
on and on about how
i'm gonna follow him which is super
weird
i can't get an answer if she's married
or not to the bottom of it i'm gonna
follow him
because i guess people seem conflicted
on the issue how do they not know if
he's married or not because maybe he
made a joke
angela wallace oh i'm not sure oh he's
following zero people what an
interesting fellow
follow but why is it so quiet i can't
hear any costumes
you just found out about the whole thing
they do want you to keep watching okay
it's like borderline unwatchable when
she does that i
physically cringe and i want to turn it
off well what happened so bad
oh remember ethan is also a host of the
podcast and he has similar
problems i have to be honest kevin klein
does not do any research for this
podcast
at all like any time trisha says oh i
have beef with this person
ethan almost immediately sides with her
for some reason which results in like
entire episodes dedicated to beef that
trisha made up he also says really crazy
things
on his podcast that are very easy to
fact check with shane it's not like he
necessarily did anything yeah it's all
like bad jokes from a lot okay so
okay okay this guy made a whole 20
part or no he made a whole documentary
about shane dawson is a very complicated
topic let's hear what he has to say i'm
here
right now that we're best friends i owe
him i
i do think from your perspective you
meant like compared to
um chris deleo yeah this
yes he didn't actually like chris dylan
commit a crime on
well well i guess that's debatable yeah
i guess it's debatable
right okay let's hear
like actively doing slimy so i've kind
of talked about i think maybe he felt
personally attacked because i was like
well shane didn't do anything wrong and
he has like this
his this huge video about you know shane
needs to be canceled
i haven't actually watched his video to
be totally honest because
let me pull it back and d'angelo we are
best friends so don't take this as a
slide we are getting anything
yeah it's all like but how long is this
video a long time ago right whereas
chris is like it's hour 13 so
maybe i should watch it you guys want to
watch it on stream no
the d'angelo episode
so i've kind of talked about the good
parts of the podcast i've kind of talked
about the bad parts of the podcast but
um
now i'd like to talk about the ugly
parts so first of all treasure pages has
had
more than the ugly mental breakdown on
this podcast they
very much played the first one up for
laughs because i mean they were wearing
halloween costumes it was kind of hard
that was not a joke by the way just to
be honest with you that wasn't played up
that was
yeah one every meltdown and fight we've
had it has been 100
genuine we didn't go into an episode
being like oh we're gonna fight
the fact that it happened is me as uncle
fester just kind of made it funnier
or made it something funny that wasn't i
guess but i'm gonna be honest the
second time that she stormed off of the
set it was not
at all funny no it was very clear to me
that she was mentally unwell in that
moment
yeah she later confirmed herself i agree
because i'm really trying to balance
this video out since this is ethan's
podcast as well
i think he plays a huge part in this yes
like i said i truly believe that he does
his best to manage
trisha paytas and her outbursts it's
like once they happen he's
really happy to profit off of them
basically making
podcast highlights out of her breakdowns
the show in some way is kind of
dependent
on oh is trisha gonna have a breakdown
this week
and i think that's just really not great
well we have we have a lot
that's only happened twice in our
episodes that don't have her breaking
down do great i mean like the
we have plenty episodes of her not
breaking down the last one was all good
vibes
yeah but um that being said the
highlights i mean
yeah i guess i think i think the
highlights benefit us both in that it
helps promote the show and it's like
it's already in the episode
i mean it's a fair criticism though i
guess well not everyone has time to
watch the full episode
but i mean yeah it's like it's like i
guess it's a fair criticism on one hand
it looks like that but on the other hand
it's a notable
episode it's a notable moment that
everybody's talking about
people are definitely going to clip it
and put it online regardless
and so it's better for us to do it than
other people to do it
yeah that is one thing we've learned is
that if we don't do it someone else is
going to do it
right and so what i don't know this
whole charade of like
it's part of the show it's like there's
i can't like
decide like we're running this business
right and we have this whole
highlight uh
system and it's like all of a sudden if
something sensitive happens i'm just
supposed to ignore it like it didn't
happen
i don't know for me it's just it's part
it's all part of the show
and it just if we put out the episode we
put out the highlights you know what i
mean
but i get it i understand the criticism
for sure
i i'm frankly torn when that happens too
i go i do have this internal debate like
do i should i highlight this should i
just
should i not and and it is something i
think about but ultimately i just decide
like look it's on the it's in the
podcast
it's part of the highlight you know so
that's i guess my my thinking show to
run and i don't think that's a very
ethical choice to make
trisha herself has confirmed that she
struggles
with bpd and obviously that excuses
absolutely none of her behavior but i
don't know what what his point is that
he we shouldn't be doing a podcast
together because that's all it is it's
like
she has bpd he says it's not ethical and
we shouldn't be doing i don't know
what's the solution just don't do a
podcast together you know what i mean
i mean that's a fickle argument because
then what can we say about the video
he's making right now
i mean yeah maybe the 180 on you buddy
i mean friend of mine that's why people
are making videos about it
that's why every t channel lives for
frenemies
right that's true yeah i mean like what
what what's the solution is that
everybody nobody's allowed to collab
with trisha or do anything with her
because she
has borderline borderline personality
disorder you know what i mean
it's like we both really enjoy doing the
podcast
at the end of the day you're a friend to
her you you said you've told her you
know i'll always be here for you and
you've always tried to be understanding
you know so i love baby
but i agree with you yeah i i i
do i do try i don't know if he's we
should finish
we should let him finish his thought
because that isn't necessarily the okay
let me i'll finish
it a bit but there's still choices that
she's made and i believe it becomes
really obvious that she has bpd in
situations like this
and i don't want to tune in for the bpd
breakdown show
i truly find that horrendous a lot of
people
say about the show like oh trisha is
such a bad
person by the way i try it my best to
avoid the bpd breakdowns
and it's happened twice and i've tried
my best to
i don't know what to do when that
happens okay and so like i agree i don't
want th i don't want that show either
dude
i much prefer when we have like episodes
like last week when it was just the
the steamies or this week the steamies
you know that was fun it was wholesome
everybody enjoyed it
and um that's the show that i want
because
we all just want a fun sustainable
experience
i don't want my life racked with drama
i mean whenever it happens it's really
stressful on all of us it's not like we
just
um it's not like a game to us it's like
we all don't know what's happening we
don't know if it's the last episode if
she's gonna
and i feel like maybe by now that it
happened twice we're kind of learning to
understand her better and like
recognize it when it's happening and
understand that it's gonna pass and
she's gonna be
like over it but especially the first
time we were all so shocked we really
didn't know what it meant
what was gonna happen next like yeah
and well the second time was even worse
and ethan is such a good person for
putting up with her
and i love him again i mean yeah trisha
kind of is a bad person
but i don't think any of that has to do
with her breakdowns or the bpd
at all i agree and i really don't think
ethan klein is a saint
i hate him again putting up with him
okay i understand
because if you haven't noticed he's also
putting up with
a ton of views i haven't even made a
video about trisha paytas
by herself yet and probably won't in the
future
specifically because of how many mental
issues she deals with and if anything
this podcast has
really just shown me like there's a lot
there that i'm not even qualified to
handle
and i truly don't believe even klein is
handling it in the best way possible for
what do you want we're just i'm making a
podcast with my friend i'm not [ __ ]
this isn't clinical therapy i'm not here
to fix her i'm just making a podcast
with my friend dude
her either gets views but at what cost
basically
it's not it's not any cost it's just a
podcast with two friends bro
we can all collectively decide to stop
it at whenever we feel like it's gone
too far
but so far all parties feel that it's
okay
i mean i feel like his argument is that
breaks down to if
anybody does anything consistent
consistently with trisha you're
exploiting her
or in some sense because she has meant
uh
a borderline personality
you know i've seen trisha for years on
youtube and i mean like
this show is the first time like where
you actually treat her like a human like
it's it's so messed up like just go look
at that david portnoy
podcast look how they [ __ ] talk to
her like she's not even a human pork boy
anyway from this anyway maybe i'm maybe
i'm overreacting
i love i love d'angelo can i collaborate
with trisha paytas or tonight
just do it on her only fans besides do
it on what
already anyway you want to see what
for her either gets views but at what
cost basically what i've learned from
this
is if you're going to collaborate with
trisha paytas
um just do it on her only fans besides
you'll make more money anyway well i'll
be here all week folks at 2pm central
time if it's monday wednesday
okay weird comment yeah all right i
guess i'm doing only fans
i am doing only fans i am going is that
okay with you
no look i understand the concerns i am
i am sensitive about it but at the same
time it's like
we're just friends doing a podcast
ultimately you know
well he says at what cost i mean i mean
it's fine it's a
it's a legitimate um
conversation to have we even had that
conversation with ourselves and we
i love d'angelo
we were wondering if we should continue
it or not but
we all on um not on the show we all
talked and we
felt we came to a good place you know
ethan me
my brother and trisha so we all feel
we're in a good place and
if things don't continue in a good place
then we don't have to continue the show
yeah of course for now everyone is
enjoying it so i actually
i think it's good for trisha because i
feel like
she does have these a lot of people
assume that trisha is like
just totally faking everything for
attention and i think that it's really
shown trisha to be an actual real human
being who's not just like
it really exposed her
human side that people didn't really see
and so i think she's happy that people
have this new understanding of her
i certainly do and so i think it is
actually i know it doesn't look like it
at times but i do think it's good for
for for everybody you know
it's been great i love
d'angelo wallace send me your wiki feed
bro
only fan's comment was bizarre i think
he was kidding it's a joke
it's a joke but it's it's just it was
kind of a weird
note to punctuate the video with but i
think he was just kidding yeah
i do love his voice though my god
chocolate rain
what's the lyrics of chocolate rain let
me pull it up
it's about uh police brutality isn't it
i love
just the image of chocolate rain like oh
my god it's raining chocolate
chocolate rains some stay dry and others
feel the pain
chocolate rain a baby boy will die
before the sin
chocolate rain the school books say you
can't be here again
chocolate ring yeah everybody knows
chocolate rain dude this video has
this was one of the first viral videos i
know but i wonder if at this point it's
like
an old meme that not everyone knows does
that over a decade old
do it do a straw poll let's see if
people know what chocolate rain is okay
can you guys do it because we can i
don't know if we're gonna get clean dude
has 128 million views wow
yeah this video is is when he breathes
it's away from the microphone
if we're gonna get claimed do you think
he's gonna claim our ass for chocolate
rain
possibly yeah let me just mute it i'll
sing it over here
i met him by the way at a friend's house
he's voice that's that is his voice
chocolate rain and then he so when he
breathes
he turns away from the mic that's kind
of the epic here
ain't dry and others feel the pain
chocolate ring
a baby
[Music]
i move away from the mic to breathe in i
can never tell if people like this song
or if it's just
a meme it's it's a box it's epic it's
kind of both
it's kind of both i think that's the
mystique of it here
here's the results put in discord okay
i feel like everybody knows chocolate
rainbow let's find out
i can read some donations if you guys
want eighty percent well twenty percent
no don't know chocolate rain fam
if you're a younger viewer i could
definitely see yeah i mean this was a
long time ago
so this was well here let me give you an
internet history moment
this is 2007. that means yeah this is
back when videos were square on youtube
right and back when like youtube there
would just be a viral video and youtube
would just show to everybody
right and it was shared everywhere too
this guy said no one knows chocolate
rain particularly when song
by ethan oh really what okay here let
here let me
let me give it to you from the man
himself we couldn't do a sing-along you
guys want to do a single there's a
karaoke version
oh there's gotta be it's gonna be
there's for sure gotta be
here you guys want to see karaoke with
declines let's go
oh yeah here if you guys want karaoke
with the klein shout it out in the chat
let him know why are you even suggesting
that
because i know you hate the idea here
let's do a sing-along
beautiful idea okay get ready to sing
along
[Music]
is
only in the past is what they say
chocolate rain
waste your neighborhood insurance with
chocolate rain
makes us happy living in a gate
chocolate rain
made me cross the street the other day
chocolate rain
made you turn the head the other way
chocolate
history quickly crashing to the bed
using you to fall back down against
chocolate rain
i gotta pee that's chocolate rain is
everyone singing zack i liked your uh
i was taking the highs i know you're a
little harmony that you're coming in
with that's nice
that's pretty epic
so pretty much he's famous for this
man he's got a great voice though let's
see what he's up to these days on his
youtube channel
hey
he's still around oh this is his most
recent one
let's see what he's up to hey he's jack
what the [ __ ] chocolate rain is jacked
didn't he
he looks deep-ass v too isn't it yeah he
looks great
you think he's got do you think what's
his name
tazonde how old is he
good question well that video was from
2007 and he looked
like a teenager then so probably
38 years old does that shock you zack
are you disgusted
instead of like you're disgusted
he just looks way younger
he's got a fresh look looks pretty good
for 38. this is a christmas song i wrote
[Music]
oh my god one
day this is from four weeks ago he's
looking jacked doesn't he
last he's jack
[Music]
you know what's funny he sounds like an
asian dude doing an english accent
what interesting like
hear me out listen closely
like he sounds like a like a japanese
dude doing an american dub
or something i heard out in space
[Music]
nobody hungry
it's a special christmas song it's a
[ __ ] original
bop this is a christmas song guy bro all
right
how's everybody doing today
anyway
so now you guys know this should be 100
now
everybody change your vote to yes
chocolate rain what else we got
man we're work we're working through any
any uh call let's do a call in our
donation or something let's
[ __ ] interact i have some donations
go
go for it um laws for uh
five euros says uh hey i also have
borderline personality disorder and i
want to com
compliment ethan on how he handles
tricia everyone please read up on the
disorder
i crimson for five dollars says i've
i've been also watching trisha for years
i agree this is the best content i've
seen from her we can tell you really
care about her
thank you i do thank you thank you thank
you thank you
i understand i understand the guys
trying to make a you know
trying to have a conversation and make a
video and stuff but
looking a little bit further back in the
donations i see
one person donate a couple people
donated a few bucks
asking how you become a member uh there
should be a join
button they don't understand video
there was an issue that may have not
been resolved yet on
ios if you're on an iphone the button
doesn't show up i think the way you can
do it is if you go to youtube if you
just go to a browser youtube.com
h3 podcast slash join
apple doesn't show it on their phone
yeah it's a weird glitch and
i don't know some weird like i think
there's some kind of contract dispute
between youtube and apple because
if you add it through apple apple wants
a cut
oh that probably is why that makes sense
right because they won't yeah yeah
well you can circumvent that by going to
youtube.com
h3 podcast join thank you such a good
racket where
you just get a cut of everything yeah uh
ryan webber donated 10 said zach how do
you feel about bel delphine's video
oh we were meant to talk about that i
don't know so
okay this is huge wait i'm going to go
to the bathroom this is huge news
so ela you want to talk about care bears
coming up while i go to the bathroom
okay great
um we got this
epic collab with care bears that we've
been working on
for a long time and it's gonna come out
january 21st and i can't wait
i don't have any photos to show here but
we're gonna start posting about it soon
um
there's gonna be a few pieces for female
specific stuff
for one for the women and
there's gonna be um a cool variety
of items so the teddy fresh bear does it
have like a care bear
you know how all the care bears are like
have like a
the share bear so cheer bear
oh we have a fun show no we didn't um
no i don't think that we could do that
fair enough because
it's it's pretty complicated whenever
you do collaborations like
yeah what you're allowed to do yeah and
everything goes through a lot of
revisions of getting it all approved by
everyone
but we did draw our teddy bear like in
the care bear style
and it's got like a tf um stitched on
his tummy but it's not canon is what
you're saying
okay the teddy fresh bear is not canon
to the care bear extended universe
yeah it's it's care bears legends okay
yeah it's scary's legend
yeah it's uh metacannon expanded
universe right the expanded universe
uh it looks really cool has i seen a lot
of the pieces two dollar donations
saying elo you look bomb
and that sweater is everything oh thank
you oh that's hot
um it's from my my vintage stuff
i love i just good i'm telling them
about cara bears
nice um
yeah and i just 20 21 is going to be
really exciting with the refreshers
at release every month and
there's going to be a lot of cool things
so many collabs exciting stuff that i
can't talk about but care bears
is coming out on the 21st the all the
clothes is amazing
we did it care bears we did it no i've
been working on this forever
you're a boy uh ben davies just now
donated 100 pounds with the message yo
i'm drunk
[Laughter]
what's a girl gotta do to find love as
the h3h3 bachelorette
i mean we've never had a bachelorette oh
wait yeah i'm dead
what about someone like whitney cummings
she's single right
she's kind of perpetually single but i
don't know if we have enough eligible
bachelors in our audience
yeah yeah for women right although zach
might want to take a pass
i was going to say i know one person
who's signing up zach you don't have a
[ __ ] chance in hell bro
you say that you don't have a chance in
hell dude
you say that you think you can pull
whitney coming
i'm gonna go down in flames trying
to get to the flames that's the attitude
man that's
it they were they were they were
flirting a little bit when she was on
recently so
and i'd love to go through again
she wants a guy who will eat her ass i'm
the man
like a can of mayo even better
like like exactly eat your ass girl like
a bag of horsey sauce
[ __ ] a man straight shooter right
here trisha messaged us
she didn't yeah she said the live is
great
thanks for being great oh okay oh she
said people were wondering what she
might think of i was afraid
i don't know i don't want to always say
yes she said
oh she loves that if you want to collab
with piersa do it on her only fan she
loved that of course she did
it's not happening trisha this is way
better
just a quick update from our friend ben
who donated 100 euros
yeah he donated a hundred more and he
said nah bad
stop it oh my god
you're making mistakes you're gnarly
dude come on man you're
gonna donate a hundred dollars it's kind
of mean but i just came here to say no
please to whitney cummings she's the
worst i don't give a [ __ ] what zack says
dollars
on whitney what do you hate that's my
queen
damn 100 bucks just out of pure hate
that's that's real spite right there
spike money yeah well i have a good idea
we should do zach as a bachelor and then
trisha picks the contestants she could
get her revenge
oh that is good oh zach's single zach
would you hear our bachelor
i would love to be fun because zach is
like open
interesting interesting you don't like
the idea ela
the thing is we kind of have to wait
till cove is done because he
he can't really safely meet people
that's true
it's not really the best time to be what
does ian think about all this
what what what's your hesitation why are
you hesitating
about zach yeah the zacher
the bachelor i think it's kind of
betrayal yeah okay you're looking at ian
for backup
yeah but zach are you ready to settle
down because you have to remember the
bachelor is about finding love it's not
about finding someone's ass
i feel like yeah i feel like actually
hesitation
well i here's the thing i i actually am
looking for love
like you ready to settle down all jokes
aside like i am looking first
you're just looking for a [ __ ] place
to stay outside your parents house
like in all seriousness that you're just
looking for a date and then
no no i i i at the end of the day i
really am a a relationship kind of guy
do you watch the bachelor in the actual
bachelor i do yeah
okay so you know how heavy they all take
it it's like i mean
that that you know i just i i would love
to find love to be honest i think people
forget too
zach was in uh a long-term relationship
for right for a while
but like for the first year right zach
the first year that you worked here yeah
you were in a relationship with him
you know he's just i'm looking for i'm
looking for a special person
all jokes aside okay let me let me throw
this out there
if there's any eligible women out there
start messaging us where to the podcast
wait oh
really why what's wrong with that should
we set up an email you guys approve of
that
you're going to get like a million
emails let's just start sorting it and
bookmarking it and just preparing i
think we should make a separate should
be a separate email for that
we'll make it okay so scratch that to be
determined
we should make a separate email because
that stuff will just
know now yeah it's like bachelor of
foreign
gmail.com we're really doing this are we
launching well let's just
yes let's just start get let's get
things moving
i think it's gotta be bachelor with the
age three
zach satchel bachelor you don't like
zacher
oh well you probably could get that one
this is i'm i'm so happy
oh meanwhile let's talk about belle
delphine's because
okay so bel delphine put out her
hotly anticipated pornographic video
on christmas day now zach
of course was there now were you waiting
for the release of it like how much were
you anticipating this video
i mean tremendous yeah i'm gonna bring
it to cynical z
cynical zack again so were you sitting
on her
only pants page refreshing or how what
was the process of waiting
yeah so i wasn't sure like when what
what
what midnight or what what time she was
going to drop it because she's in the uk
so um yeah i was just refreshing and
then she kept posting like oh a couple
hours away and i'm like [ __ ] like
you know [ __ ] me so
so well if when it finally came out what
time was it in the middle of the or what
time was it in the day
uh i think it was around 4 p.m
and were you were you
at what point did the uh
how do i put this without getting
monetized
the sec the act were you smashing your
hand
no i wasn't smacking the ham and this
was more of i was
going into this as a roger you didn't
smack your hand to the video
no i was going like a giant
like like a jean shallot you know
like and actually wrote it i don't
believe zach is watching this [ __ ] for
scientific value
that's [ __ ] zack oh my god
okay maybe i rubbed it out once or twice
there's the truth
yeah okay and so zach had mentioned to
me that he thought it was a perfect 10.
now i saw a lot of people on the
internet complaining that it was
um disappointing
but that's not what you thought about it
um
i actually wrote a little roger ebert
styles
um
she posted it for free on her only fans
no actually is that called quiet
yeah zack's really quiet can you hear me
one two one two
talk a little bit closer mike she posted
it for free on her only fans
no extra charge the whole thing is like
she's having sex with her teddy bear
so it's some dude with a bear mask on
having sex with her
she used tentacle dildos like a bad
dragon type
whole thing was like 13 minutes long at
the end she holds up a ps5 and says
thank you teddy
and gives the bear the ps5 i would call
this nothing short of a cinematic
masterpiece
and here's why after the sex scene the
teddy bear wakes up from a dream
uh and fears excuse me a tears for fear
song starts playing a mad world
as if the dream was she was having sex
with he was having sex with belle
overall rating zach two thumbs up wow
i think it should be like two tissues or
something
thumbs up you know what i mean we need a
different depends on where you're
sticking two bottles of lube what are
you sticking those
feel thumbs up thumbs up doesn't sound
good though because it sounds like it's
two out of ten
or two out of five no in america the
thumbs is synonymous this is a this is a
yeah okay everybody knows two thumbs up
yeah it's this got it
we love it two thumbs up
didn't they used to give like half
thumbs like it's so weird i give you a
half a thumb
yeah i think they were always pretty
definitive on on that show it was two
one
upper [ __ ] down that's all so there
was this famous show
they gave there were two movie reviewers
and they would tell you
two thumbs up they're not yeah i love
that show
i went in as like a roger ebert of porn
so yeah that was very uh
well written thank you thank you
how many times did you watch it uh well
the first time was you know for
critical analysis uh second time was in
my bathroom
and third time was on my bed so three
times
three times you know
i still haven't been able to find that
video it's pretty amazing how they
how they uh have it locked down so much
oh expect to see it on twitter or
something but those guys really know how
to run a dmca
yeah what's the whole business i guess
so yeah
my my other criticism of the tape and
um was the uh
the money shot you know it wasn't
um it wasn't very exciting
why was the quantity low what was the
problem yeah it was a weak load
and like come on all that and you're
gonna shoot a weak load
and uh they could have framed it a
little better
you know oh okay so we have some
criticism of the
load the load size yeah thank you zach
incredible well thank you thank you zach
by the way somebody another person
donated a hundred dollars
another hundred dollars and said i've
voted i i i'm sorry i veto coffee cakes
hate
on whitney with this donation please
give this to zach so he can buy her
dinner
do we have a counter it was a counter
100 nation
to to cancel out the other 100 donations
holy [ __ ] no to whitney
so they want you want me to give the
hundred bucks to zach
it says please give this but to buy
whitney dinner okay
so if you land a date with whitney i'll
give you 100 bucks
i would love to go out with whitney just
like to go to dinner like
oh my god the same guy the drunk guy bob
dude
you said last one baby happy new year
and stop it
all these banks with these all these
yeah and all these chargebacks
charge back they're going to remember
the original person who donated
hating on whitney donated another fifty
dollars said okay jeez if he wants
whitney give the man whitney
okay all right we have uh we have
consent we have green light
people are going wild in the chat
message whitney right now
be like yo we're live zach wants a date
what do you think
you have zero percentage you're 20 how
old are you you're like 23.
but i play the guitar like a mean
[ __ ] and she said that she likes
younger
guys right on the last episode oh my god
yeah i can i could serenade her i could
make her cry
yeah i don't think she's looking for
that
but i did see a lot of interest in the
zacher
yeah i think zach if she's interested
zack she can apply it through satchel
i will write her a song i will do
anything for her
so actually we've probably been going a
while right how long we've been going
uh one hour and 40 minutes so before we
um
sign off and when you get drunk ben on a
call someone asked
and if you're if you're in the discord
uh
message me message zachary well we'll
get you on he's probably too drunk
do we have those only fans uh creators
the great girl was doing like poop porn
and stuff
do we have her on the yeah they're in
the uh waiting room yeah let's get them
on
so you guys may remember we had a call
with this
couple who has like a fetish oriented
only fans and they do all kinds of well
stuff like pooping and peeing and
they're just like down for whatever and
they're also like devout christians or
something which was kind of a weird
twist
um wait no i think she said that she was
raised in a very
conservative household i remember i
don't think she's still well
we're about to talk to her so yeah just
ask so anyway she was on our show
and apparently she a lot of our fans
went
and ordered and supported her to the
point
where she actually
actually made a lot of money and so my
question to her is like what
what are our fans ordering i want to
know i'm going to bring her in
should i bring her in what's your name
again uh
it's anthony and reena reena
that's marina yeah bring them in they're
on the line
rina rina
rina hey hey oh there we go
reena how are you
good how are you are you a devout
christian
no oh okay i thought you said you went
to church every week or something or
maybe you used to
grew up no my family was very
conservative growing up we didn't go to
church but i currently don't
can turn up a little bit yeah what is
your does your family know what you do
for a living
my mom does yeah is she cool with that
yes she buys me lingerie oh
really cool mom yeah supportive mom's
role
that's good so since your last
appearance on the show you had a lot of
uh support i guess on only fans right oh
my gosh
yes these foot soldiers really
were very lubricated and ready to watch
my content and i was very
happy they are so nice lovely
that is going on okay so yeah that's
what one i want to ask you
next oh that's weird because we're all
about the wiki feet
but okay so i want to know about real
all of a sudden all the fans came to you
what kind of fetish videos did they buy
from you break it down for me
have you ever heard of fruit looping no
oh boy
i'm scared it's basically
when you gape your [ __ ] and your
partner eats cereal
out of your ass what wait that's a thing
[Music]
yeah why is it called fruit looping
because your ass your
your prolapse looks like froot loop
typically
typically fruit loops would be the
cereal of choice yeah
and did somebody ask you to do that yeah
three people asked me to do that three
separate people asked you to do a fruit
loop
yeah because i had a video right before
where he was eating gummy bears out of
my ass so they asked to fruit loop
and how much did they pay for a fruit
loop
it was 150. you got it you got you
really you have to charge more
weight
[Laughter]
what's your process of preparing for
that
so i end them on my [ __ ] and then
i put a butt plug in for the whole day
to
to loosen my legs 150 bucks this whole
entire day activity
you got to up your prices girl it's good
in there you know so it's like it's a
win-win
okay so then at first i i've never froot
looped before
so i had to look up how girls did this
so
when we first did it the milk kind of
just went in my ass
and then it wasn't rising you know like
it wasn't acting like a bowl effect
so maybe so we put her we put a makeup
sponge in my ass
so there was like some type of bottom
let me put the milk and the cereal in oh
my god
and so you fill your ass up and but so
oh it's not about necessarily the
prolapse it's just open wide
okay yeah like it's gaped yeah you have
to no oh
that's what it's called do you have to
perform some kind of thing with your
muscle to gape it or is it just
naturally gaped
at that point after wearing the body no
i have to like push out
and relax myself otherwise i it's so
like it won't work you know
right it closes up on you yeah and so
you get on your back
your partner pours milk in there and
then he ate the
the fruit loops i'm assuming well i get
in doggy position
and then my [ __ ] is basically up in
the air
and he just kind of spreads it and then
you know we do a pov shot of him eating
it out of my ass
did he give you a bite yeah
yeah he spit it into my mouth
three separate people asked for that
that's incredible i have to say
yeah that is incredible that three seven
people requested that
and did they give you feedback when you
got when they got the video from you
yeah they were just kind of like oh can
i order another one
but it wasn't for looping for the rest
of them it was like other
other types of things did i wow and so
um so
when you when you were getting the milk
out do you just kind of [ __ ] a bunch of
milk out how does that work
yeah i just kind of like projectile
falls on the floor kind of situation
and and it's it's fine to have milk in
that area
i mean it's milk i don't really know you
have [ __ ] in there i think so i mean it
can't be worse than [ __ ]
yeah it's it's an [ __ ] so it's like
right
you know it's free rain good point it's
free rain
it's free it's free real estate
okay wow well that is that is shot i
didn't you guys
what's that a lot of people asked us to
role play as
youtuber
i don't like that okay neither do i we
didn't do it
no you didn't oh that's nice nice yeah
we didn't get the consent we needed so i
was like yeah it's a no-go you do not
have consent
yeah oh my god
so we also uh you asked us last time
what was the freakiest thing we ever
done but
we never actually got to tell you but we
were thinking about it the other night
and uh
we actually wanted to tell you if you
guys wanted to hear it
sure i'd love to all right um so we
[ __ ] in a caesars palace parking lot
with a bus and i was also harboring
a nerd's rope in my [ __ ] you [ __ ]
in a parking lot
i got a process all the words you said
you [ __ ] i got that you're [ __ ] in the
parking lot
and then what was it caesar's palace
parking lot and then what was the next
thing
with uh it's um a sex toy and it has a
mouth
an [ __ ] and a [ __ ] so we call it a
busset you know like butt mouth [ __ ]
okay what did you do with the lid
so he was [ __ ] me through
the business so he was essentially
double penetrating me and the sex
toy okay and then what was that and then
i had another drop in my ass because it
was for an anniversary trip
you had what in your house i was hurt
what's the nerd's fault
like but yeah i gotta i actually got to
stop you i feel like
i feel like gaping i feel like fruit
looping is way crazier than that
yeah really well i don't know i guess
because it was in public
we thought it was like a lot crazier
yeah nerds rope let me google this
dude you have someone [ __ ] on you what
are you talking about
like that's not that doesn't she's
saying that it gets extra bonus well
they [ __ ] in public
i mean a lot of people do that yeah the
fact that with the nerds right the fact
that you added nerds up your ass
and you were [ __ ] a sex toy at the
same time i saw them do something gnarly
on their only fans what'd you see that
she pegged him that's not that that i
mean that's pretty normal zach i don't
know why
the girls had people [ __ ] on her zach
pegging is nothing did you just hear her
describe fruit looping
that's that's too you know vanilla for
me
what zack stop i don't believe you
so what else what other fetishes besides
the fruit
just when you when when people order
people are screaming stop but
i refuse this is awesome i don't
understand why people don't like this
i find this so fascinating
it's just funny how people say stop and
then like thousands of people sub to me
and it's like
kind of questioning do they really want
us to stop here
so when people request foot stuff what
are they
well you tell me what what break it down
for me the fruit looping three of those
what was the the most popular request
you got
definitely feet anything they wanted
really bad
come on and how much you charge for that
only like 50 because it's not a big job
interesting what was the most yeah i had
was the most expensive request that you
processed
oh um somebody asked
if i could put a dildo in my mouth
while my husband [ __ ] me and then also
get [ __ ] in the ass so i had all three
holes going
and he wanted like pov front shot like
top view
like just lost that was a wild ride
because he wanted it to be 20 minutes
long so holy
well they even requested all my polls
were hurting me
and so how much did you charge for that
that was
three hundred dollars girl you got to
[ __ ] step it up man i can't i don't
like
doing it yeah i know but still you've
got to make a living here gotta get paid
yeah you're putting in work i mean it's
fine that you like it but damn you got
to get paid you're working hard
yeah all right
telling me that everybody was saying
they agreed with you with that
yeah i mean someone with that specific
of a request is going to shell out more
money
ben this drunk guy in the uk just gave
us 300 pounds i don't even know what for
you know what i mean he definitely paid
more to see you eat froot loops out of
your ass
anyone request balloon popping
um no i mean you guys didn't show the
video so they didn't know that i did
that
i mean i don't think people know that
that's a thing okay well she does
balloons guys
all right everybody's screaming
over it i don't know what everyone says
you guys gotta chill bro
i like reena i thank you thank you for
describing fruit looping i thought that
was really exciting
and thank you just i'm glad i'm just
glad you guys are doing well and having
fun
and you should be charging more okay all
right thank you
all right guys god bless all right bye
so you guys all knew what fruit looping
was i'd heard of that before you oh
really
mandy can you believe that three
separate people requested it
no something with our fans like are you
thrilled
for me for our anniversary oh zach
says he has drunk bananas i have drunk
let's go ben how did you get drunk
you messaged me all right bringing them
in now all right we have the wrong man
who made three separate 100
oh [ __ ] what's going on
[Laughter]
ben do you can you afford just give us
300 pounds
yeah there's a good reason for for that
today actually i've
just got a new job today so i thought
[ __ ] it let's do it
congratulations well congratulations
that's great a good a good job well
congratulations
thank you man thanks bob all right well
thanks for calling in
that's it what do you do for a living
appreciate the uh the the random call
and uh thanks for everyone in the chat
as well i was very very kind i've had
some nice nice nice words and everyone
should say nice things about me that's
good
even though they only know my name hey
drunk ben what do you do for a living
uh i am a uh web developer oh nice
so you probably make some good cheddar
yeah it's not bad it's not bad it's not
bad but
um you know kobe it's been pretty pretty
pretty [ __ ]
so you know everyone's gonna look after
themselves and try new things so
it's all good um don't feel sorry for me
i don't
but i appreciate the i appreciate you
very much
trunk band tell me um are you just home
drinking by yourself
i am yeah my girlfriend's upstairs she
has no idea she's happening
is she gonna be mad do you guys share
like a bank account
uh no fortunately she's uh she works she
works for
aldi um sort of
uk superstore thing but um yeah i'm uh
i'm gonna be telling her about this
later in fact what i'm gonna do is show
her tomorrow the whole thing and she'll
like what the [ __ ]
[Laughter]
what are you drinking drunk ben uh i
drink stella artois which is a
sort of uh you're posh right all right
you're doing good you're killing it
yeah i call it white beater over here
really say what yeah if you if you ask
anyone who drinks stella
over in the uk they call it wife beta
why
why's that because anyone who drinks it
basically it's really strong lag and you
go home
you just beat your missus up you do that
ben
you you just basically if you drink it
in a pub everyone says oh
that guy freaking stella oh he's gonna
be he's gonna be go home
beating up his wife when he gets back
are you gonna be you're not gonna beat
your wife up ben are you
no absolutely not i don't advocate that
uh in the slightest however
those who can handle their drink then
you know it's all good but those who
can't maybe i don't know i can't speak
for them
right i can't speak for them drunk band
thank you so much
i'm glad that uh you're okay i just want
to make sure you could afford it
please don't do any charge back we love
you appreciate that all right
i've been watching you for a while you
guys here thank you brother yeah
appreciate it always since uh the um
the early memes and stuff you were doing
so all the sort of edited stuff you're
doing
yeah back in the day well thank you
thank you bye yo
all right take care thanks ben
bloke right there i thought stella was a
weak beer
uh dark um i'm not going home i don't
know
uh
i had stella it says it's about five
percent
uh it's five point two five percent it's
pretty average for a beer
right yeah your honor there's a good
reason why i beat my wife
that's not your name
we didn't have an opportunity to mention
uh that guy turned
uh of age legal drinking age
there was a post on the subreddit the
chapel the guy with football
the guy wearing the teddy fresh yeah
wait what do you mean he turned legally
oh did he have a fake id yeah it was his
birthday uh recently
and uh there was a big post on the
subreddit about it yeah yeah
he doesn't need the fake id anymore you
got to get a hold of chapel
i need travel in my life yo before i
leave
i saw this on i saw this one on reddit
this is this is just amazing
this low quality i don't think it was
this low quality when i watched it
oh my god oh boy yeah it's a bit oh my
god i'm licking it bruh
i'm snatching on the [ __ ] butt on the
subway
why he's like munching on [ __ ] too you
could chunks you could see
yes missus do you have that sound like
that yes miss yes
you're really going for it isn't it some
people are like obsessed with leather
like they rub it on their face and smell
it and i guess look at it bro he's
eating
chunks off the bottom of the booth
did he just find that i mean is this
just his girl's
is this his mistress
how does that happen to someone like bro
until fathomable abu child trauma
not only to do that but to also do it in
public unfathomable
child trauma wow
that made me so nauseous yeah why is
look at look at the suggestions
it's like asmr intense ear licking
asmr intense tingles here let's watch
ear looking asmr
why was this suggested to me related to
that video
because it seems like in the same realm
right like it's asmr to watch that it's
just kind of like bdsm
kind of weird bro i would totally be
down to watch this video is an
hour long long
[Applause]
how are people going to tell me that
asmr isn't sexual why are we having this
debate still
i don't understand how people could tell
me that asmr is not just
like well i think the debate is that
it's not all sexual
it's not all sexual okay like did you
really have to get mics that look like
ears like they look like ears
i love it can we close it
like specialized asmr uh
great do you like it zach
i'm into it in what way like
sexual way or no it's just sad it's
unsatisfying
but why the ear why does it have to look
like a ear and then she sucks it like
she's doing something sexual
god bless i feel like this is not
appropriate to watch
do you know what i mean i feel like this
is not safe for work
well ian used to watch it tomorrow what
do you think i don't think you watch
this did you ian
everyone's demanding we stop the chat is
exploding
i was watching the ps5 one i sent you
the other day you're watching
the ps5 asmr i said what the [ __ ] is
that what is a ps5 asmr
i i linked i just linked it to you i'll
type it in google
this one here it's in the discord
okay wow you're really desperate for
that ps5
oh i see yeah so this is a asmr for
people who did not get a ps5 for
christmas i
hope you are doing well
thank you although i'm pretty sure you
are not
given the entire facial hair
is a problem situation so this is
okay i understand it's a joke so why is
it an hour and six minutes
i'm gonna skip forward did this help you
ian
yeah i think it helped me overcome the
fact that i
do only have the ps4 tearing open a
wound
and smashing salt this doesn't sound
relaxing
here he's got the ps4 three
three oh no even worse
i'll power it on so you can enjoy that
wonderful sound
of the ps3 as it uh runs
see isn't this calming you watched the
scene how much of it did you watch
a good 20 minutes my god someone said i
became a member to tell you to stop
somebody uh donated five pounds said
zach must be a mediocre shag if pegging
is shocking
i don't think i don't think getting
pegged
i don't think not want to get peg means
you're a bad lover
i think it was more about uh cause zach
said he
he was shocked by seeing the pegasus i
agree it's not shocking
you got busted zach i wouldn't say it's
shocking it's just the fruit loops i
mean i've seen it a hundred times man
you've seen fruit looping oh yeah bro
how is this not porn
there's two look at this this is like
more sexual than any of the weird [ __ ]
we've seen
two girls double teaming an ear look at
that there we go
this is crazy stop
dude look at this
this is not safe for work right it'd be
hard to explain
oh they're twins oh my god you guys
the twins are back
oh they must actually do porn because it
says
first they have a patreon what's with
zach
yeah let me read the comments if you
love youtube then you'll love youtube
live
this is uh bro
no just imagine watching this and
someone walking in
you know that joke where you say i
turned on porn real fast it's easier to
explain
this is pretty epic youtube think i mean
should this be considered pornography
because it has like 800 000 oh wow this
was just uploaded
last month and it already has 800 000
views so this is pretty
this is big time this is a viral asmr
video
so do you think this should be like
age restricted because technically it's
not showing anything but my god
right thoughts
yeah they're not actually it's the same
girl oh no
the frame is divided down the middle if
you look carefully at the mic when she's
touching it you can see
that's actually pretty cool i have to
give her props on that's pretty creative
all right all right you mean right here
yeah yeah oh well that actually makes me
appreciate this more
in a way doesn't it i mean good catch
whoever
noticed that cool
with some howdy look at this thumbnail
anyway i don't know what else to say
we had a good run didn't we pretty good
let me see if there's any other videos
we can watch real fast
um oh what did you get a bunch of people
donating and said
that they're wearing headphones and
these asmr videos are
killing them yeah right are these real
or elaborate fakes somebody explain what
the [ __ ] is going on here
zach zach went through a lot of effort
to prove that these are elaborate breaks
okay
there's a power point in the dock right
below this lane because so
this went viral on tick tock and when i
saw it i was like man how's this guy's
head not on a bike
did we talk about this no no no okay
and so i was like how's this guy's head
not on a pike he's on tick tock and he's
getting the queen
yeah it's not the coin but it has 8
million likes and people were like dude
what is this and he has a whole series
of videos of him apparently
uh getting the queen on tick tock and
not giving a [ __ ] about her
why would they
why would they fake this all for a tick
tock
let me let me view some of his other
ones oh yeah you're off frame
you you're just cutting off frame slowly
i am
you there's another video of him with
the queen apparently let's see
it looks yeah that's not the queen she's
like in some weird like
corners she's just like in a closet what
the [ __ ] is going on
yeah that's not that's not the queen you
were adamant that she was though well
at first because there were so many it
had so much engagement stuff but let's
see what the
let's see your powerpoint i'm curious
hours and hours
yeah exactly proof it's not queen
not batwing all right
here's queen elizabeth yes thank you
zach
great research so far thank you thank
you
ours the imposter right okay
nice little zoom crop there
[Laughter]
side by side i mean it looks the same
it looks like the same person if i'm
being totally on that actually looks
more like them
that looks just like her dude it's the
same haircut but if you notice the
facial features
it's off you're talking about this face
that's like
entirely shadowed and pixelated exactly
the same queen that's it
yes wait wait these they look very
similar
don't they it ain't the queen sure they
look similar i don't think it's
exactly that guy would be in [ __ ] in
a ditch ian you see this powerpoint
learn from zach you know i am a little
intimidated i gotta say
i worked hours on it somebody donated to
talk about skippy
is there why what's up with skipper
what's up with skippy did he send you
some
pancake art he said he posted a new
video yesterday he had covid
oh zach you could have watched this that
doesn't look like the queen at
all and obviously the queen isn't taking
selfies with people
you were adamant on it though you were
like this is the [ __ ] queen
i wasn't that adamant
brad this is horrible
the ruse is up dude you shouldn't have
posted this
okay so what about skippy what's going
on with him so he had coveted he's
better now i talked to him yesterday
great i was messaging with him um he
has a new pad um i'm good good
he um he's getting back in the dating
world
and in his new video he posted he's
going after mormon milfs
did he explicitly say mormon mills
mormon elves
yes and he's on some mormon dating site
and he reached out to five people
uh his wording exactly
yeah good was um
one said she would think about it one
said no two haven't responded one might
be a
fake profile but i'm trying someone said
they think about it what did he say to
them
uh he said hi i'm guessing i'm not your
type but i have a youtube channel with
25
000 subscribers i was wondering if you'd
like to chat
with me about being single and you can
promote your youtube channel or
instagram or whatever
let me know if you're interested skippy
this is not how it's done so he's
honestly first of all he's saying i'm
sure i'm not your type
he's putting himself in the friend zone
right up the gate right
like dude skippy yeah comes on
he's on a site called mutual which is a
mormon tinder
and then he's gonna make a hinge okay
well he's
he's he's trying
also uh look at what i just put in uh
discord
did he do he told me that he was doing
some kind of uh
okay dan whatever it was a whole
conversation dan is trying to expose me
here's from our whatsapp chat that can't
be the real queen
it is for sure
[Laughter]
um did he send you he told me that he
was going to commission some pancake art
for us
okay did he send that to you guys
i never
it was like a whole big deal he was
super excited he's like i'm gonna
make a pink there's this guy who makes
pancake art and i'm gonna pay him
to do pancake portraits of all you guys
i was like cool dude send it to
dan or zach yeah i have not received
i've not received any pancake art as far
as i've seen so um
what i did something yeah you still
gotta make good on that well i want it
to be like just save your money i don't
need the pancake but i don't want i
don't wanna let the guy do his thing you
know if he wants to get me a pancake
then [ __ ] it oh here's pancake wait
here's a pancake
oh is this it here it is
mute this [ __ ] music it's only a
minute long
so exactly pancake art
uh skippy got a pancake portrait for
himself
excuse me what about me i've done
everything for you
i'll hit him up oh he this guy draws it
backwards
yo i don't want to be like a pain in the
ass sack but i feel like he can't
promise me pancake art and then
renege on it i'm going to hit him up
like he just got himself pancake art i
don't know
just not right that's really cool that's
all i'm saying
oh yeah that is pretty sick yo where's
my [ __ ] pancake art skippy you paid
for your own pancake
how much your trip costs to get to get a
pancake it's like
yeah tell him that i'm pissed i'm just
kidding don't tell him that
they're saying skipping for bachelor
yeah but ah skippy for bachelor that
could be pretty amazing actually
is that actually that actually would be
amazing
no you don't like the idea he's
he's too picky he's
yeah you want to risk the perfect streak
right
i don't know well maybe what i'm doing
maybe it's not the risk maybe
i'm not giving skippy the chance to meet
true love
maybe it's not the streak maybe the
streak is perfect
by it it can't
not be perfect he's going to find true
love if he's the bachelor that's what
i'm saying
i want love yeah well take a back seat
buddy
you ain't making me no pancake art
neither did skippy
yeah let's take a vote okay
okay let's send it to straw poll do
people want skippy or zach
there's someone here saying please stop
with a constant james charles hate
when you can say your pro shane dawson
podcast and he has actually done gross
stuff
do better wait will we read it again
please stop with the constant james
charles hate when you can say you're a
pro shane
dawson podcast and he has done gross
shut up dude james charles
our [ __ ] design he's out there
spreading covet at least shane as far as
i know is not trying to kill people he
directly
did something against ethan and eli
sister snap
it's [ __ ] person okay also most of it
is jokingly it's not
yeah well for actually i do think james
charles is a massive douche i'm not i
don't i'd have no beef with shane
but shane i mean but james charles is
out there literally giving people covey
like he doesn't give a [ __ ] dude
and also as far as i could tell he was
inside the capitol building people are
asking questions
sister's snatched bruh we've talked
about the shane stuff it's not like
we're completely ignoring it there's
clearly
a lot of uh it's a complicated situation
we've talked about it
you're doing a poll dan yeah okay good
is it out
posting it right now all right this is a
good one
okay zach or skippy you guys decide now
you already posted one
post it in discord so i can see number
one what
post it send me the thing i'm i'm
posting it in the chat for
you guys someone else posted a different
right now well that one's not official
here's the real one which one what do
you mean
just don't worry about it some random
person made a poll that that one doesn't
count
this is the real one what is ian that
random person
yeah i made it it's all good he's not a
random person he's ian
just said somebody else did it's okay to
himself as somebody else
it's fine dude send me
[Laughter]
sorry having a dead air moment cause
nobody's sending me the pole
it's a cop
okay zach yeah people want zach i saw
ela voted for zach
don't excuse me thank you
anonymously
not anymore that's a clear one for zach
but that's okay skippy we'll find you
love another time
you feel good destroy destroying
skippy's dreams zack
actually no because he's such a
kind-hearted dude and like
he's such a nice guy and yeah but i feel
so
well maybe we'll do skippy after all
right
i feel like we've we've definitely ran
out of show here
you know what i mean a little bit
but the good news is it's the weekend
we've had a great fun
week we're gonna be back next week some
more great content
uh that's it you know thank you for
everyone who donated
any are any donations we should read aby
someone asked what's our new year's
resolutions i'm trying to find the name
i don't make new resolutions
every day is a new day me neither did
anyone make a new year's
nope yeah resolution was to not play any
sound bites in the background but i
ruined it the first show
you see actually it's the one that new
year's resolutions suck
it's like the whole concept of it is
very depressing because
it's just setting you up to fail if you
really want to do something don't wait
for the new year
little drummer boy said please have zach
you can't miss the opportunity to call
it the bachelor
right yeah that's actually one two it's
pretty good all right
how do i join the discord channel i'm a
member uh link your
discord account to your youtube account
in the connections tab in discord and
once you've done that you can
another girl saying i totally agree the
obsession with james is weird
it's not weird it's fun
i'm not that obsessed i'm not like how
obsessed am i
you're obsessed i'm not upset
let's get glam it's just fun
i'm not like thinking about them all day
can an aussie
sign up for the batch
different area code different country
sister all right before leaving please
watch the teddy fresh commercial
i'm not sure what is that i don't know
what that is
guys the show's over it's clearly over
thank you so much thank you everybody
thank you to our members
to our donators starting next week we're
putting everything up a day early that's
not live we're going to make an effort
to do that including frenemies you guys
deserve it
god bless you thank you all um it's in
love
peace love what was that guy's name uh
d'angelo love him
what a great best friend best friend
best friend i followed him on twitter he
doesn't follow anyone but
he's the best we love
um let's enjoy the weekend
even though we can't do anything we
don't have a car this weekend it's gonna
be
oh this video i made a commercial for
teddy fresh
i'm afraid to watch it because if i
don't like it then i'm gonna feel like a
dish
you know what i mean
this guy is relentless i'll
i'll throw it on here here's the
commercial for teddy fresh god bless
uh i i'm also afraid to play the music
because i don't know if it's cooperate
or not
i mean this is sick bro
thank you dude
thank you for coming into all my
livestreams as well promoting i don't
want to spam and get in the way of
you know people doing their jobs that's
why i finally decided to
upload it here to youtube so please if
you for any reason made it to this video
and you think it's worth being watched
by ela
please my fellow h3 teddy favorites
we're watching it now
what do i mean you skipped like three
minutes
[Applause]
i mean it's cool it's just it's your
friend wearing a hoodie
hello my name is diego i'm a filmmaker
and i made that commercial you just saw
this was a spec commercial which means
that i made this for free
in order to pitch it to the company i
just legitimately don't do
yeah thank you for making that but what
am i supposed to do with that
oh god it keeps going james is better
than you guys that's why
five million subs and you can't even get
three okay katie
katie is totally james i love talking to
you
katie west over donations wait is the
donation minimum five bucks
no you can donate less than so why does
she keep giving me like a ton of money i
don't know
he's not the brightest the [ __ ] out
james is the best
no james sucks you now your turn right
i disagree james a [ __ ] now your turn
he stormed the capitol
oh my god this is the t hi sister
okay do you want to say anything to him
stuff to do so it was probably not the
best timing um to reach out to them
would it be funny if we bought the for a
commercial but didn't use this part just
used him
just use this and i wanted to make a
commercial
for them
but he's spamming it in the chat i
didn't want to watch it because i knew i
was going to watch it and be a dick
like i knew that was going to but then
why did you put it on there
you sent it in the discord somebody said
in the discord i didn't
i don't know i mean god bless him you
know what i love the guy
he's took a shot you've got it in front
man fair enough and not
sister oh i it's clearly i mean what am
i supposed to do with it do you want me
to run it on tv i mean it doesn't make
any sense
do you know what it means it's my fault
i've given false hope
to the fans amy what did you do you
talked about what did you do
no no not to him i'm saying just that
now like all the applications i get are
like i've been a fan for like
eight years like they really think i
just got a job from simping
well you did
he did kind of okay
he invited a lot more applications i
thought you're supposed to be relaxed
baby on the bench
but what is it he's chilling i mean i
mean no i mean god bless the guy
i mean he just yeah he's been spamming
it like every episode and he came into
he's been coming into my lives as well
wait
drunk ben said to katie you donated
another five
and he said hey katie drink stella oh
drunk
[Laughter]
this guy's been spamming your chat ab
yeah my live streams
i mean he's a nice guy i'm not not [ __ ]
talking i'm just saying it's not
it's not it's fine he's a nice guy i
think it's a good man it's a little
weird
he's spamming abs live
what are you kidding me by the way it's
it's pretty cool but it's not that good
to be spamming abs live
with peace and love of course i'll take
the heat for ethan i agree
i mean i mean it's yeah i mean as i
spent in i made my video on ethan i
would never have spammed it like i never
would have thought that's the way to get
in front of ethan and ela
[Music]
someone sent me an a photoshop of me in
front of a
like a cover of a comic book and said
i'm trying to get a job on the show and
this is me showing my creativity
with peace and love my my forehead was
cut off but
i didn't understand right though i'm
just saying like everyone's uh
everyone's trying to get a job yeah i
wouldn't force it if it happens it
happens you know a b was out there
we came across across him the thing is
ian did it before
anybody thought to and ian went through
a very careful vetting process
i think so right then didn't you vet him
yeah we did if you do i mean
we just gave him an interview i mean it
wasn't that deep
didn't do a background check on him or
anything dan called me he said
you want a job yeah most elections
happen
i met dan at a coffee bean and like we
hit it off and like
well yeah well you would you had emailed
a couple times uh
zach had emailed right when we were
talking already about
hiring a sound guy so it was very
coincidental it was like the next day
after we had a conversation about it
got an email from zach saying i'd love
to offer my services so i met with him
and
we gave him a shot same thing with ian
right you guys met at a coffee shop i
don't think that i think you guys
interviewed ian that's what i'm saying i
don't think i vetted
ian no nobody kept an email
into the office you don't remember
anything dan that's not what happened
right ian
[Music]
uh wait we gotta have a
hold on katie's talking [ __ ] again and
out of 4.99 she said i'm convinced
everyone in the comments anything and
eva
not ela and ethan not ela
and jealous of james success we're
arguing with the 12 year old at this
point
dude i just made like 20 bucks from this
or should i say i just made 20 bucks
from her mom who's going to charge back
katie i disagree you
now your turn no katie i'm just he sucks
charles sucks can we get katie in i want
to talk to you yeah
so real quick i just messaged skippy for
the pancake videos and he's all i
emailed him to you
and he emails me a google drive folder
and there's nothing in it
dude that's like did you guys ever do
this trick in college where you
put like you changed the extension so
it's corrupt
so they can't open it and then you have
more time to do it that's what skippy
just did
so ian what actually happened with dan
um dan called me
yeah one day he goes
yeah you know what you're doing he's
making all this
now i want to know what happened you
ever seen a camera
i said once or twice he went you're
hired
and then i came in no it was very brief
he asked me a couple questions
and uh then gave me the address
[Laughter]
no one met me i just walked in one day
dude damn i was an impression that dan
like vetted you and [ __ ]
and that he likes you and he met with
you look at your mind also confusing
that whole story with zach because
that's
a psycho into my life
me no because you emailed us a bunch and
i was like you know what maybe this guy
there's something to this ian was
emailing me a bunch and i knew that we
were going to need help
so i was like it's nice that he's that
consistent and he really wants the job
yeah
so i was like well maybe at some point
we'll have more time but i don't have
time to really check in on this but and
then when we had then i was like
dan can you can you check him out
that's how i remember it yeah i'm sure
he could have killed us bro
he could have straight up strangled me
live on the podcast
he still might i trust him christina
here said it took me 10 minutes to
figure out how to do this
just to say i thought zach had a porn
star girlfriend how can he be the
bachelor
you already broke up with the porn star
already we're we're friends we
just yeah what happened with that
relationship i'm curious can i talk
about it now i wanted to ask you yeah
um i mean we're friends what happened
did she dump you or did you
what happened no i i decided that um
i thought we'd be better off friends and
um
you know i'm not i'm not going to [ __ ]
talk or anything because she's a great
person but
um did you guys do any freaky stuff in
the sack
uh no comment oh
um yeah drunk ben is still going
i just found the first email ian slater
ever sent me hi
my name is ian slater i've been welcome
i've been speaking with ela about
interning for the podcast and she passed
along your emails so that we could sort
out scheduling
i'm currently putting together uh
personal info or whatever thanks ian ps
i've been loving this in the news
segment it's fascinating thanks ian
fascinating such a dick sucks
that was you sent in a resume i've never
even seen that segment
send the news look at you trying to suck
up the dan
it worked i'm here yeah and it's a great
thing so i'll reach out by phone
tomorrow
blah blah blah great talk to you then
and then we talked on the phone
i said nice chatting with you looking
forward to having you come in and give
him the address and the rest is history
so you're just getting the address like
that you had already vetted him i didn't
listen to the emails
i said dan bet him make sure he's not a
freak
yeah i spoke to him on the phone that's
not a bad you can't exist
a vet is meeting someone in a coffee
shop like you did with zach
yeah you didn't give me the address
right away oh well like it started off
with a phone interview and then you went
over my resume
because you seemed like a weirdo zach
but he didn't seem quite well without
what the [ __ ]
listen you trusted me to vet in and look
what we have the [ __ ] all-star of the
podcast
in the [ __ ] god okay it worked out
nobody calls me in the god i do
you know i have i just i do have one
confession with that call i remember
when i talked to dan he asked me if i'd
switched before
and i'd said yeah i switched on this
podcast
once and he said was it like a physical
machine and i was like
yeah and no you were just lying about
all of that
you made all that up i didn't ask any
follow-up questions dan like what
software what machine
i'm sure i did ask him and he didn't ask
i switched for one show one time on the
computer
but dan had said oh was it a physical
machine like a blah blah blah
and i said that yeah or uh or he said
yes and you're like cool
kill us all and he said oh nice
here's the address bring your [ __ ]
favorite knife
which is exactly what happened we're all
dead in heaven right now
damn i was i was on the toilet when
ethan offered me i wasn't using it but i
was hiding in the bathroom at work
and my old job really i thought i'd
message you in the middle of the night
i was uh getting out of my astronomy
class when i uh
emailed dan you confirmed fascinating
you brought it up how does that work
this is interesting stuff guys
it is kind of uh i get it
diego said all cool thanks for watching
i appreciate you guys
did uh that girl did the did the james
stan
donate any more money oh that's a good
question you dan
i think diego should keep making videos
oh diego right that's what started all
this here let's watch i agree
he's a great cinematographer around the
week
of their last episode of the podcast so
they were probably very saturated with
stuff to do so it was probably i want to
watch diego dan you sent it oh watch the
actual commercial he said
i did it i did he watched like five
seconds oh my god it's just
her wearing the color block and it's
like
by the way dude i don't even think she's
wearing our hoodie our beanie
how are we going to do a teddy fresh
commercial if she's not even wearing a
teddy fresh beanie
that's a good question like bro what the
[ __ ] interesting you know what i mean
that's not teddy fresh
nothing in this shot is pretty fresh
it's just a shirt this
this is not french this is not tedious
it's not teddy fresh
like what you know what i mean like okay
she's wearing a shirt
under a coat
[Music]
yes did we make a podcast that's the
email
i watched are you happy dan what i
wasn't encouraging you you're like
watching
i just say i i know what was in it i
thought you want me to tear it up again
do you want to watch the three minutes
of him talking well that's the majority
of the video
great cinematography i'm looking at
people saying grape in the chat that's
why why are they
and the haters everyone bro i can't even
hear diego
why is everybody talking what kind of
[ __ ] show is this where everybody
talks over each other at the same time
you know we're all being a little too
harsh on dan i just got to say the send
the news segment was really good
[Laughter]
actually maybe we should bring back send
the nudes though
we did for like a minute right ben you
gotta stop donating
making me worried oh no stop ben
drunk ben ben he said actually he wants
a job
don't stop and there was another one
that we didn't read
i'm sorry there you go there that one
can you check out my history podcast
comic strips i sent them to zach he said
no chargebacks only glory
oh nice
should i watch some more of this guy's
videos
i'm curious now diego
my filmmaking let's go
your boy diego let's [ __ ] go
we got swords
yeah cauldrons yes
queen yeah
yes yes yes oh that's pretty sick
i wish you pulled those stops out for my
commercial maybe i'd be [ __ ]
interested
the budget was way higher and this oh
it's like a play
all right take a you had your shot how
come you don't want me man
did we make a email for the bachelor do
we have one
too late for that i gotta wrap it up
i'm hungry you want mexican food can we
order a mexican
or just seat of leftover hummus can we
talk about food off the show
people like this i feel like people i
feel like you're the only one that likes
i think people are interested in our
intimate conversations about food
i think you're just telling that to
yourself i agree the chat
loves it yeah i love it people want to
hear it every single time it's like so
do you want pizza tonight or
so okay but let's just pretend like
they're not there
okay you're a fat fat shut up trisha i'm
trying to
have dinner ela
yes should we eat hummus that's in the
fridge or should we order mexicana over
it
the hummus yeah that's funny because we
bought a shitload of hummus and then
it's good it's in the face oh you want
to get some upstairs
we have pita and everything it's really
good my stomach is like making noises
right now so do you want mexican or
pizza or like italian
i shouldn't eat pizza but mexican's much
healthier than pizza
agreed because pizza yeah yeah pizza is
just
i mean it depends if you're a huge
burrito but i'm saying nutritionally
there's so much more in a burrito
pizza's just cheese and bread i mean
i guess but i guess you could say that
to yourself but
you've got to agree that there's more
nutrition in a burrito
because you've got meat you've got rice
you've got guac you've got
beans you've got all these complex
foods and then pizza is just bread and
cheese
right does anyone agree with me on this
am i crazy
i guess they agree with me baby what are
you doing with your hand
oh i was picking up the pineapple so i
could eat it
why are you really you're really
committed to this island thing i go all
in
pizza is actually very nutritious papa
disagrees with me
well i don't care i'll eat anything you
know you know i'm a skinny thing ethan
is using fat logic
wait i am you guys think i'm using fat
logic
i mean yeah wait i can't tell yourself
that a burrito is good for you
i'm saying between pizza and a burrito a
burrito might be
healthier because it has more maybe
violent eating fatty shut up trisha
it doesn't involve you you're fat fat
fatty
wait just so you guys know i've been
exercising every day since
break i've definitely lost weight i
don't know how much
i'm doing really good i'm even people
people have been calling me a skinny
legend you are looking very good
i have to say thank you zach anyone else
[Laughter]
looking great thank you baby that was
not i love pizza
did not say that was convicted what is
everybody saying grape stomp for
i don't know what that means i mean i
know there's great great stomp videos on
youtube one of my favorites is a grape
stomp video you want to watch it
the lady of the lady falling or whatever
yeah yeah i mean
tom fail that what they're talking about
here
they're saying calories or calories
okay okay these are filled with chambers
and grapes and
the winner this saturday who stomps the
most juice we'll actually win an oh we
got a donation from
james charles are you ready to try it
yeah sure
hey sister two bucks thank you james you
still
think you're a dude
[Laughter]
ben donated 20 more dollars said bye i
have to sleep now
good night good night you're going to
relax go to sleep
very good i'm sorry yeah i'm sorry just
email dan if you want us to return it
too
at least watch the grape stomp
everyone's begging for it whoever stomps
the most shoes
wins it overnight today but it's not the
only thing you can do the measuring cups
you can come and spend the day listening
to live music eating international foods
having wine tours and tastings vineyard
tours
seminars arts and crafts it's a lot of
fun
just trust me we've watched this video
[Music]
the tv oh they want us to watch his
injury video can we even i thought it
was buying a paywall
trailer or the clip of it tom segura
accident dude this [ __ ] was so crazy
i just want to watch the clip i think i
watched this guy's video and this is
where i saw
this doctor breaking it down he got so
unlucky well he's not the typical
okay yeah i i feel horrible i mean he
got so messed up from this
i just got he got so messed up from it
and
like the tearing of the ligament is one
thing
while he's not the typical athlete we
cover on this channel tom segura
suffered a
you know it sucks it happened so fast
and like so
so much damage happened dude it almost
looks like just a normal fall
like but but no this shot is
unbelievable
yeah and then bert comes and re just
puts his arm back which apparently was a
good thing apparently that was i heard
because i thought i was like oh wow bert
just like ruined his life
yeah i would immediately think don't
touch but somehow burnt is like an elite
athlete knows everything about the human
anatomy and everything he does is right
but here he is he just readjusts his arm
look at this
oh my god tom looks like he's passed out
i don't know if he's conscious
like look at he doesn't even move when
bert readjust his arm
so not only did he tear like his foot
ligament
but he fell on his arm and broke his
whole
[ __ ] arm like that's the part where
god's just like [ __ ] you
i feel horrible i mean it's just
horrible it's a horrible energy
just from a friendly game who would have
thought
oh that poor guy i just feel horrible
for him
he said sister snap sister snap for sure
oh brother he's he's all i mean he's
just not
he's doing good he's a champ he's in
recovery you know
all right is the show over so do we
decide
i can't do it on the show oh no
somebody says dan you started to read my
comment about an h3 comic strip
and got me so excited that my heart
jumped only to forget it and skip over
it feels bad
well i just read it now so what happened
what are they talking about
james charles says stop using my name in
this trash podcast
thanks for the three bucks james oh he
did that
all right i gotta end this thank you
guys send any tips you have about james
charles in the capitol building to the
fbi where's the comics trip
i don't know okay it's just it's just a
donut see you next week
have a great weekend
you know and the whole damn crew goose
and gaps with all the guests you'll see
the best podcast in the world take it
from me jc
over chair hp baby we podcast
now you're watching h to the three three
three
three you're watching h to the three
three three three
you're watching h to the three three
three
honestly shredded was